Oh good Lord. Ladies and gentlemen,
we're back round two. That's right.
We don't fuck around.
Buya uh,
this episode is brought to you by
nature box. What's naturebox? Man,
we'd be hungry at work here. That mouth
of noise that you know what that is?
That's um, we're kissing. No dairy.
Get bear pressure. That's sweet.
Blueberry almonds. That's a nature box
product. Fucking God damn delicious.
You want to try something
to have someone else?
It's not as good as the Sriracha cashews,
but I almost fucking lost him today cause
young Jamie tried stealing that shit.
Hiding it, hiding the
Sriracha. Cashews you fuck.
Are those rocks cashews controlling or
you got too many of them over there?
He sounded, which take them off. He's
got too many. I'm obsessed with Serratia.
Serratia cashews are the Shit
I put Serratia and Coleslaw.
Sriracha cashews are one of the
delicious snacks that naturebox has.
Hundreds of different delicious
snacks. Guilt free, delicious snacks.
And they know why it's still zero trans
fat, zero high fructose corn syrup.
You can find snacks that
are low on sugar non GM.
Oh and without gluten.
They ship for free instead of eating
that bullshit that you see in vending
machines, you can get nature box delivered
to your place of business, your home,
what have you every week.
And you have, as I said,
just a ton of different options.
If you go to naturebox.com/rogan
you will get 50% off your first box,
your months first box. You will
enjoy these. They are fantastic.
I cannot support them enough that
I've never had one that's bunk.
They're really delicious and
I'll a lot of different options,
hundreds of different options and uh,
like I said,
really healthy stuff. They
don't use any bullshit, nothing,
no trans fats,
no fructose corn syrup,
all that fucking shit that's bad for you
or just typed in mature box instead of
naturebox. Whoops. Don't eat that.
It's a mature buck.
That's not what you want to eat.
Bert Kreischer I'm going to get those.
The Racioppa fucking things are amazing.
They're so good. Yeah. The cirrhotic
cashews I'm addicted to, but I'm,
I'm a big fan of these
blueberry almonds too.
These are fucking delicious as well.
naturebox.com/rogan go
there and like I said,
get 50% off your month first box and
I guarantee you you will get hooked.
Um, I, I've,
I've sent many people there and a lot
of delicious and nutritious options to
choose from.
Go there and enjoy naturebox.com
forward slash Rogen.
Uh,
we're also brought to you by legal zoom.
Legal Zoom is an awesome way to deal
with a lot of stuff that would be a huge
hassle to take care of ordinarily legal
stuff that you would have to go to a
lawyers office, you'd have to make an
appointment, you'd have to drive there.
You'd have to do it between the hours
of 8:00 AM and 5:00 PM generally.
And a, you would have to do
all of it with your clothes on.
You don't have to do any of
that with legal zoom.com.
You can get personal wills,
you could do powers of
attorney living trusts.
They've been doing it for over 10 years.
Legal Zoom has helped protect your
assets with Llcs, s corporations,
trademarks, real estate
documents, and more big,
big fan of legal zoom. I'm a fan of
doing anything online. I love it.
I love the fact that you can take care
of all a lot of shit that you would
normally have to go do.
You get divorced if it's amicable,
if a missus, whoever the fuck your last
name is, decides you look, she's done two,
you're both done. You could come to an
agreement, you can do that shit online.
How glorious would that be?
Legal Zoom has an a plus by the
better business bureau. Better.
I should probably say that smoother. Uh,
but a plus pretty Goddamn groovy. Um,
that just shows you that there's a fuck
load of people that have used legal zoom
and have benefited from it tremendously.
You don't get an a plus from being an
asshole. And for a special savings,
be sure to enter Rogan in
the referral box at checkout.
Legal Zoom can also hook you up with
a third party attorney if you're in a
fucking frothy panic. If you're filling
out your forms and you're like, ah,
I'm gonna go to jail. Legal Zoom can
hook you up with an independent attorney.
Um, they provide self help services
at your specific direction,
but they are not a law firm.
Ladies and gentlemen,
legal help is furnished through
vetted independent attorneys. However,
call or visit legal zoom and they will
take care of you from start to finish it.
He's the modern way to get legal
help. And again, for special savings,
be sure to enter Rogan in the referral
box at checkout. That is legal.
zoom.com use the word Rogan.
We're also brought to you by
[inaudible] dot com that is o n n. I. T.
The human optimization site.
What we sell is all sorts of things
to improve the way your body and mind
function, whether it's strength
and conditioning equipment,
whether it's healthy foods and snacks
like the warrior bar or the hemp force
protein bar. We just started selling
coffee, started selling caveman coffee.
Uh, we have an on it blend now
brought to you by our pals, um,
Tate Fletcher and Keith Jardine
from Caveman Coffee Company,
a single source coffee provider, a single
estate medium light roast coffee. Yummy,
delicious. I have some right here in my
mind. When I followed Tate on Instagram.
Dude, he's an interesting guy
to follow his life because he's,
he's not like a look at the sunset
kind of guy. No, he's, he's like,
I'm teaching a child kettlebells.
He's an awesome dude. Period.
There is no dispute. Um, so I'm,
I'm very excited that we
started carrying his coffee.
It's a really excellent coffee.
They've worked very hard to, uh,
establish this relationship
with a single source, uh,
in Colombia. Colombian amber. Um,
which was single source means is
they get it directly from the grower.
The grower. Um, they have a direct
relationship with the grower.
The grower takes it, they pick it,
they take care of it, they roast it,
they send it to Albuquerque,
and uh, Albuquerque sends
it to us, the Onnit roast.
Um,
we also have the best strength and
conditioning equipment we can find,
whether it's steel, maces,
steel clubs, ab wheels, um,
all stuff for functional equipment,
weight vests, medicine balls,
of course, kettlebells including the
Zombie Bells and the primer bell,
primal bells,
artistic kettle bells.
In fact a supplements as far
as far as our supplements go.
We just try to find what is the stuff
that has science behind it was the stuff
that has actual scientific references
we could read up and try to figure out
what, you know, there's
a lot of Hullabaloo.
Let us Hooli when it comes to supplements
and there's a loss of a lot of
opinions.
One of the things that you find is there's
a lot of people that like to say that,
you know, certain supplements
known, do anything. Uh,
Alpha brain is especially a controversial
because it is a new tropic supplement.
What nootropic is the idea is that
it enhances cognitive function.
Of course,
that's kind of controversial.
So because of that we have performed
not one, but when we did one,
we're in the middle of a second one,
a second clinical trial
plus blind double blind,
placebo controlled clinical trial,
positive results from the first one.
We're very excited about it.
Um,
there's also references on all
of the different ingredients.
There's been studies done on all the
different, uh, aspects of Alpha brain,
but we wanted to prove that the
improvement, uh, wasn't just,
uh, based on the individual ingredients,
but they had a synergistic effect.
So we're very excited about the positive
results and we're very excited also
that all of our supplements, whether it's
Alpha brain or, um, shroom tech sport,
which I have never heard a
single negative thing about.
It's based on the court steps mushroom
and the quarter steps mushroom is
something that the Chinese Olympic team
used to a achieve a Olympic gold medals.
I don't know. It's a good question.
Okay. I could read that. 37.
I'd rather just go through it. Why 37 was
about a year. I had a rough, really rough
anyway, this, this commercials too long.
So go to a on at.com o n n I t use the
Codeword Rogan and save 10% off any and
all supplements. All of our
supplements have a 90 day 30 pill.
Moneyback guarantee.
Not just money back guarantee,
but you don't even have to send in the,
the, the, the case, the bottle. We just,
what we're trying to do is just sell
you the very best shit we can find.
And we do it directly. We package
it, we distributed and um,
because of that we can achieve a
quality and efficiency and also like the
strength of the ingredients.
We just by the very best stuff on
it.com use the code word. Rogan.
O. N. N. I. T. Oh Kate. That's it.
Let's go. Bert Kreischer is here.
Why fuck around when Bert Kreischer
the Joe Rogan experience.
Joe Rogan podcast by night.
All Day.
My man
crusher,
world traveler.
Internationally known locally
respected trip flip. How many,
how many trips have you done so far?
Uh,
30 40 40 40.
We got another 14 we're doing
starting this weekend too.
That's a lot of fucking trips. There's a
lot of fucking the international trips.
And how many years has this been?
This is going to be our fourth year.
Fourth year this, so 10
international trips a year for
four years. Holy Shit Dude.
Yeah, that's a lot of fucking
ambulance. A lot. Do you know what,
just started flying sober. Whoa. The fuck
is that about because I just met you.
Okay, look, I like partying
and I'm like getting down,
but it's just like by myself on a plane.
Me Drinking Ad Nauseum,
it's just not healthy.
And have you gotten more comfortable
with flying that you're able to achieve
this? It started, I took a flight to
Hawaii with the girls and Leanne was like,
let's try it and I,
and I don't want it,
didn't want to get hammered on the plane
with the girl's way and normally do on
a flight to Hawaii. So I didn't drink and
I just, and I got there and I was like,
oh, I took his hand. I took a half
a Xanax. Yeah, we talked about this,
the last podcast actually.
And then I've been working on
it and so like I like our fly,
I'll be with red bound Thursday night
in uh, in San Diego. And then we,
I fly in Friday morning to Phoenix. I
can do that sober. That's a quick flight.
And then I fly back to San Diego. I can
do that sober. And then so short flights,
I'm good at long ones from Miami.
I have a hard time, six hours,
six hours I start getting in
my head because then I'm like,
what happened one time was I was on
a flight ticket from New York to La.
And like halfway through we are in
really bad turbulence and there's no way,
there's no instant gratification.
I can't put a Xanax in my mouth and
it just kick in. Right? So like,
so there's no instant gratification. I
know I have like half a Xanax in my body,
so I'm like, fuck it, I'll drink. I don't,
and I know that's bad, but I was like,
I'm going to have a beer and
then it'll heighten the Xanax.
But then I felt like I was having
a heart attack, so I was like,
motherfucker on those flights I got
to roll the dice and pick Xanax.
So I go through like a weather map and
I looked to see what the weather is on
the flight la. And if it's bad, I'm
just like, this is a drinking flight.
And I get that.
So this is a drinking flight.
And I get that there's no way around it.
There's no way around it.
It starts in Miami airport and it's like,
yeah, I don't like to drink on praise,
but praise.
I don't like to drink on planes,
but I have and I've achieved
some excellent moments.
Like I've had some real fun on planes
being drunk and also real good writing got
done on planes. I would like to
drink Budweiser for some reason,
which I don't normally drink,
but I like aluminum cans of Budweiser.
I like aluminum cans of Heinikin full.
Can I say,
give me the one and I don't want
to get a portrait. I want the,
can I say that I'm very specific.
Well you went under the best
feeling to right as my, like my,
this is my fucking moment by
zone is if I cannot drink,
uh, for, uh, for any of the part
of like the, any of the pre board,
any of that.
And then I get one beer before takeoff
and then I take off of the one beer.
My system, I start fucking firing.
Cause I've, I have the fear of death.
I have the life. I had the life going on
like, Hey, this could all end right now,
but I'm like, it's not,
I know it's not Gunna,
but then I just start jamming out
material and I just write like panicked.
Like I,
at one point I wrote on,
I was like first time I did it was all
done and Napkins and on the everything I
was writing on everything.
It was for a roast I did for cow head,
said Bam and it out. That's
a really good feeling. Yeah.
There's something about being in a plane
that gives you that heightened state of
vulnerability that makes your your
creativity sort of fire up a little bit.
I wrote my book, I wrote my
book on a plane. I was on
plane flights to Australia,
to Switzerland,
to Italy to Scotland and I just get on
and I just started drinking and just bang
it out, write drunk, edit sober.
So I get in my hotel room that
next day and be like, all right,
let's take a look at what I wrote. I
could not read at at time. I was like,
I know this story was this chicken it.
Do you write longhand?
Do you write typing?
I write better typing,
but for jokes I love the art of,
I'm a little, I don't have it on me,
but like do you see like,
uh, like I love to like,
like this past weekend I
increased the size of my,
my road book because I wanted big
cause I want to really like focus.
I feel like I'm wasting my forties
by just fucking around on stage.
I want to really write and know what I'm
writing and work on that material and
make it better. What do you mean by
wasting? Like one where I get this? Uh,
I love the live by the sword,
die by the sword moment on stage.
I love taking chances
and I love experimenting.
The problem is I'm not paying any of
that off. So it's not like that's,
it's like a,
imagine if I loved fighting,
but all it's doing is doing
bar room barfly street fall.
It fights, you know, like,
and I didn't take Jujitsu classes
and put it to some sort of use.
So that's what I feel like I'm doing
on stage is I'm having a good time and
they're amazing shows and
they are one of a kind.
But if I do have a moment
of really good writing,
I'm not then taking it and doing the real
work of sitting in the green room and
writing what worked, taping my set. So
I just started taping my sets and going,
all right. But those little tiny
notebooks, I have a hard time,
like they're good for your pocket by have
a hard time getting inspired to write
in it like,
but those big ones I do.
So like I'll write a big letter and
then really right around the letter,
like almost like it's an old school
book from like the, you know,
like the 18 hundreds. So that's
what I've been doing. So you,
I use those little books
that go in the pockets.
I use those for just right
before I go on stage notes.
Like I write out like set lists and
stuff like that or new ideas that I can't
let go. I write them down on
that. But uh, I'm, I'm with you.
I write most of my stuff on a computer,
but I like to like write long hand for
memory. Yeah. I just started my eye.
It's impossible to write a book, obviously
shorthand, but I found the quick,
did his, are you serious?
Longhand? They call it, you know,
it's not shortening the
shorthand. Is that weird? Um,
you know that weird you
ever seen shorthand?
Like it's called Gregg Gregg shorthand.
It's like a that they used to
use tonight. Rivers, courts,
demographers and um, no, I don't think
they use a typing. Yeah, you're right.
They have some weird typing method,
but reporters would use it. Yeah. There
was an article about it recently because,
um, I always knew about it. I
never understood it, but I, um,
I was reading this article about this
new product that I just picked up.
I still haven't implemented it yet,
but what it is,
is a pen that is an MP three recorder
and it also takes photographs of your
notes. So say if we were doing this
podcast and I had the piece of paper,
what I would do is you would
say something. I would say,
Oh shit, Xanax on a plane.
And I would write it down like I had an
idea or there was something that we both
said that I knew that I
need to revisit or whatever.
And then if I wanted to go over my notes
afterwards I go to the pen and I can
put the pen over the note and it would
play the recording that was going on as I
wrote the note.
Fuck yes. Isn't that
crazy? That's fucking,
oh, that's personally wizard shit, dude.
Let me tell you what exactly what
you know what that's good for. Oh,
that's a good for a lot of shit. I
was trying to think. I'm trying to,
I try to remember my dreams,
like a excited,
really fucking insane dreams and I
think that you can find out some,
some sort of your subconscious
creativity throughout your dreams.
Yeah. Yeah. I think that
would be, oh well, let's see.
The thing about this is that it records,
you know,
the idea is that you're recording an MP.
It's really for like
people doing interviews,
like that's one of the best things for it.
But it's like if we were doing
an interview, I'd have a pen,
I'd be able to write down what you're
saying or write notes down on what you're
saying.
But I would have the entire room
courting who it's not going to,
you can't find your pen and you just
write the tail end and you're hurt and you
heard. And that's how I cured
aids. And you're like, dammit,
I should have written the beginning
of this. Yeah, let me find this thing.
Just so everybody knows what
we're all here. It's called,
it's called the live scribe sky Wifi pen.
It's very,
very interesting.
I just signed up for fucking nature
box while you're doing your ads.
I just bought six months. Those seraching
things and the bluebird thing sold me.
So tell me this one. I'll buy this
one. It's called the live scribe.
Um, and it's, uh, it works
on Wifi. Um, this one,
the one that I got is eight gigabytes
and uh, it's incredible, man.
It's really an amazing invention.
I say this having not used it even once,
but uh,
it has uh,
uh,
very high reviews on online from
reporters and from folks who use that.
My idea is that I'm going
to start using it for, uh,
for podcasts because I have
all these notes like, you know,
that are all scribbled in and I go over
them at the end of the week and try to
find it. Cause every now and then one
of these will become a bit, you know,
one of these things that I
say is worth, um, like here,
vampires colonizing Mars. Oh, preppers.
I Dunno what the fuck that means. I
have no idea. But if I had the pen,
I could go over that and it would tell
me the exact thing we were talking about.
What vampires are colonizing Mars.
If you get a pen or with the David
Tell joke where you get a parrot.
Zody said, I, he goes,
I ain't go. By the way,
here's what I'm done doing.
I'm done.
Idolizing the guys that I
idolized out loud. Like I,
I think Jim Norton is one of my
favorite comics. No world did.
Then he came over to my podcast,
I should have just sucked his dick for
an hour because literally I sat there and
I was like, I just posted it today
and it's getting like tons of hits.
But everyone's like one hour,
like, like they were like,
you really were blown because I love Opie
and Anthony and I listened to the show
all the time. I love
tough, tough crowd. Right?
And I listened to him on your podcast,
which was fucking amazing.
And then he came over to
my house and I'm like,
can you tell the story that you
told what I felt like a child?
Well, he's, you know, I, I
know what you're talking about.
It's hard when you have genuine
admiration or you know, you,
you want to express it,
but you're trying to figure out how to
not be like so fan boyish and just get
over it. But that's also part of the
enthusiasm of being not just a comic,
but a fan of comedy. You
know, you're a fan of it.
Huge Fan.
I'm more,
I would say sometimes I'm more a fan
than a comedian. Like cause I love,
I love laughing,
I love laughing.
I go online and I'll watch
videos fucking all night long.
I watched Patrice has elephant in the
room. I might watch that once a month.
No lie.
You know what my favorite joke on
that as man, one of my favorite bits,
I think it's from elephant in the room
when he talks about what position is open
or girls get mad, you know that you know,
I want more out of this relationship.
I want this and things like that.
That position is not open.
And it was like when you go for a job,
you don't say,
I want to be the CEO of a company.
What that position is not open.
The position that's open is I come
over two o'clock in the morning,
you suck my Dick, I drink your
last Snapple. That position's open.
It's fucking such a good bit.
My favorite.
It's so like defines and when,
especially when you're single and you
know every man and woman who has ever been
single has those moments where you're
with someone where you like, yeah,
this could go away and I'll be all right.
You know,
like girls need sex just like guys do.
Don't play games.
I did to grow who admitted to me
that she was using me for sex. I go,
I am cool with that. You know, let's
just, we got it all out in the table.
Let's just use it like that.
But you know,
there's people that get into situations
where you feel that way but they want
marriage, they want you to be the number
one and they'll make you feel bad.
Like you're doing something wrong.
Like you're a piece of shit because
you don't want what they want.
And then Patrice, the way he like
labeled it out, they're like, no,
that position is not available here.
Here's what positions available there.
Tell me if you want.
It
makes that joke genius in my opinion.
And I love those.
This is what I loved about Patrice
was the, the truth of it. The,
the fact that that is actually all and
you know it's true because you know he
drank her last snap.
That's the best part of that joke
cause a lot of comics would just leave
it as the piston is open ones where you
suck
my dick. Right. Cause you think it would
end big. Right. That's a big hard word.
But the one paid trees Patrice great
was and I drink your last step that adds
the flavor. You know it's like the extra
spice in the stew. It's like Dwayne,
he said my favorite joke on that whole
special is a, he's like, oh I like,
I didn't know how important
things are going to be.
Like I never learned how to type.
And he was like I didn't,
I was too busy calling people gay.
We're going to steal lunch.
Me Bitch.
And he's like,
and now I can't type so I can't talk to
anybody because you don't realize how am
I remember taking typing classes
and going and exactly what he said.
I'm not going to be a secretary
cause that's when we were kids.
If you took typing and you're good at it,
you're like great, you'd be a secretary.
That was it.
That's how will the world was set up.
You didn't realize everyone
would need to learn how to type.
I do not think it's that
hard to learn how to type.
I had no problem wearing a hat, a
type. I didn't take typing in school.
I didn't take it.
I learned how to type.
I learned how to type because I've got
a computer in college and then worked
like,
but it was hard.
Why was picking and poking for
like the first couple of years?
Then I got one of those Mavis baking can
typing programs. Do you ever done that?
No. That's awesome. Um, I don't
even know if they still make it,
but what it was was essentially
a program you would run,
you'd run it on a CD Rom and it
was a game and it would be like,
it would tell you to press
the r and you press are like,
it was like you're racing and like the
are would come up and you'd have to press
the od,
the tea would come up,
you press the t and you're supposed to
do it all without looking and it shows
you on the keyboard where
your finger should go.
And so you just do it and then eventually
you kind of know where the are is,
where the t is, your, your fingers
are on the j and the F and you know,
you figure it out and you just learn
how to type. And it didn't take long.
I mean I type now really clearly. I
type fast, I don't look at the keyboard.
I type pretty good. Brian
to this day, he's like, oh,
can you believe we can tell you without
looking at the keyboard, it's bullshit.
I'm like, you've been typing as long as
me, you lazy. Fuck. Just learn at a type.
Like you're saying it.
Like I wish I could breathe underwater.
It's not like hard stuff to do.
I mean I did it.
It was not an effort. It
wasn't like, oh my God,
I can't believe I'm still
doing this and I can't type.
I can type without looking,
but then I have to go back and make sure
I did the right letters. Really. Like,
cause I, if I start typing I
can do it. I can totally do it.
But then I got to look at it and go,
okay,
you're looking at if you're typing without
looking, you're looking at the words.
No, I meant, I meant
like looking away. Oh.
Like I can type and look at
the page but like I can't,
I can't like type and look away
and then type like I have to look,
I have to be seeing that I'm
writing the right letters. Yeah, I,
well I definitely think I don't,
I have typed like having a conversation
with someone and it'd be okay. But yeah,
you want to look like at the
actual screen as you're typing.
What I mean is like looking down at
the keyboard, hunting and pecking and
I had a disastrous situation
once with this guy.
I got paired up with a head of development
deer and they paired me up with this
guide or to write a script and uh, there's
a lot of things wrong with this dude.
He was going to full blown panic
attacks when we have meetings.
I mean full blown panic
attacks where he couldn't talk.
He had these crazy anxiety
attacks. Um, and uh,
the other thing was he couldn't type and
I couldn't believe it. I'm like, you're,
you're a professional writer and you
can't type. And he's like, well, you know,
writing is about creativity. I go,
it's about putting me in a little,
put it down on paper while you're still
thinking about it. Yeah. Like he couldn't,
I mean it was the war.
It was like he just started typing today.
It wasn't just like he was bad at pecking
a poking cause hunters Thompson picked
and poked the day he died.
But he would, you know,
he had this thing where he would do it
and you know he figured out how to write
books by pecking and poking.
It means,
it's funny if you ever seen video
of hunter s Thompson typing. No,
but I feel like I have Jamie.
Thanks.
See if he can find a video
of hunters Thompson typing
cause it was kind of funny.
He would just get these two index
fingers and just charging. He had this,
it's kind of spastic thing. You would
do his arms up in the air and it was,
it was really intense.
I could probably lose three fingers and
still type cause I think I only use like
this one and my two thumbs,
my two pointers and like one up here.
I don't think I use all things.
I don't use pinkies.
I use all of them. Really? Yeah. You get
that typing program man, you should do it.
It'll help you a lot.
It'll definitely make you type quicker.
I know they have some typing programs.
I don't know if they still have
the Mavis Bacon, but that's what I,
I need to learn how to read out loud.
But
this is a mother fucker was packing
and Pocan and um, he also would,
would have the, I mean I got it from
fear and loading. Oh, there. Okay.
Well this is sort of a,
an imitation of it by Johnny Depp.
This is sort of like how he would type
and this is Johnny Depp doing it in five
years.
It's him playing liner as Thompson.
You'd probably pull this down and then
we're going to get fucking pulled off of
youtube anyway.
Probably already pulled that one off.
We were wanting money from you. You've
referenced something in pop culture. Um,
but this dude was a professional writer,
couldn't write and would go.
He's a pitch meeting guy.
It's supposed to be a pitch of any guy.
Full panic attacks. I mean, panic
attack. So we'll have the, uh,
the, uh, the Paul of the plot,
the politic apologize. You know,
Joe's a guy who was all working
in this one applies and,
and I'd be looking at him like, oh, Jesus.
And I didn't want to interrupt
and break in because he's also,
it's very awkward when you're there and
someone's talking about you like your
qualities, like what's good about
you. But I'm like, this is pointless.
This is a way this meeting is
done. It's over. It's over.
As soon as you start stammering,
they're not going to give you a show
to run you fucking stammering. Fuck,
I can't you shit together.
Take a meditation class or something.
I'm going to breathe.
He also used to do warm up when he
was a comic quit comedy. Couldn't,
couldn't handle the comment anymore,
but it had like this weird bitterness
towards other comedians. It was very odd.
But he told me that he was in the
middle of a warmup once for a, well,
let's just not say the name of the guy
he was warming up for because we might've
already told this story and
giving up the information,
but just in case I don't want
his name to get out there. Yeah.
He would work for this.
A big name guy,
a Sit-com guy who just
happened to be black. And um,
as he was warming up the crowd,
he had this panic attack
where he got it in his head.
Yup. Did I tell you this? Nope.
I heard it on the podcast and I ha I
listened to your podcast walking through
New York and you told a story and I'm
walking to a presentation of corporate
presentation where I am the host and
I literally went, you mother fucker.
And all my brain said was
giggling. Yeah. What the guy said
his, he got this idea in
his head, don't say nigger
for no reason,
but like when folks have anxiety issues
or when folks have mental issues that,
that, that, that can happen. You can get
a hitch like, uh, like for whatever it is.
It good news.
It can just get stuck in your head.
And for him he couldn't talk and he
was doing this warm up and he was just,
when it was over, he was just
a shaking, sweating mess.
And it was just a a wrestling match to
not say nigger while he was warming up a
sitcom.
Basket ball get that'll,
I think that'll work for anyone.
And you get that in your head and
when you have to do a president,
I wouldn't let it in. You don't let it
did not about God about it. Thank God.
But I'm walking in and I've heard you
say that and I, when mother Fucker,
I don't worry that it could get you,
it's a brain thing.
I can think myself into an anxiety
attack. Can you really? Yeah,
I fall. I've thought myself into big ones.
So what is an anxiety attack exactly?
Like what is the feeling like the
first time I ever had when I was white,
it was a kid. I was like,
probably someone will say,
well I was definitely 10 years old.
I was probably 12 and I was watching
Johnny Carson and all I could feel like,
was it? He was shouting at me
and his head was real tiny,
like the like from beetle juice. His head
was tiny and he was just shouting. Yeah.
And I was like, I was like freaking out
and I went to my dad's room. I was like,
I can't, I think I'm going to die. And
he was, my dad said go back to bed.
And I was like,
okay great,
I'll just white knuckle this night
and then fucking and so then I and I,
but I didn't know what it was.
And then the next time I had one where
I realized I realized one day I will die
and I went, what? Like it got real heavy,
everything seems real clear. And then not,
you start spiraling, you get
like a blinders on, it's heels,
you've got blinders on and everything
kind of gets tunnel vision and you lose
kind of like everything feels like
uneasy and you can feel your heart race.
I mean it happens
differently for every person,
but I've kind of struggled with them a
little bit and I would get them on planes.
That's why I started drinking on planes.
But I can think myself into a panic
attack. Like last time I was here, I was,
I was going through one cause remember
I was like I have a pain in my side.
That was a panic attack. No, no,
but it was one that had been building
throughout the time and I was like
motherfucker where you just start thinking
about it and then you lay in bed at
night and your head,
you have no control of your thoughts.
How much exercise do you do? A lot right
now. A lot. Right now. A lot. I'm running,
I'm doing, I told you I
had got battle ropes. Um,
yeah I should have googled you before I
started using them by just tried to just
fucking nuts without them attached to
anything and I just basically bullet in
the head with a fucking
40 pound road. I held on to
both like, like I was out
running a stage coach. Okay.
Joe and just went and the rope just came
and my daughter's watching and the rope
came back and I just
turned it last minute,
hit me in the side of the head and I
hit the ground. And you were just like,
are you okay? And then, um, as I'm
laying on the ground, I'm like,
motherfucker and George,
he goes,
I don't think that's how you're supposed
to use them. I was like, yeah, I know.
It's why I texted you. And you're
like, put them onto a kettle bells.
Like should have texted
you before I started doing
dumbbell or you can wrap them
around a tree.
Even I put them on,
I put them on a Kettlebell and then
to put them on my grass and you know,
helps me loosen up. I have a bad
back and it helps loosen up my back.
I had an anxiety attack one weekend I
was in Syracuse and I listened to Bas
Rutten one about his arm and I started,
I started figuring,
cause I've had this back problem from
riding rollercoasters I was like,
what if I get that sound? And you
know, you've got a fucked up job, dude.
Your job is, I mean you've taken
so many people on roller coasters,
the other bed back, put your
hands up. That's so crazy.
It doesn't even make sense.
Like you might be the only guy ever.
He has a fucked up back
from riding roller coasters.
You start spiraling and you're like get
tendonitis in your elbow and you're like,
mother fucker.
I was like,
and then I ran into do that like
next week and I was like, Joe,
talk to me about back issues.
And you were like,
but like some people are prone to anxiety.
I think it has to do a lot with your diet.
That has to do a lot with your exercise.
Like when I'm not exercising,
I'm fucking gone.
I have a theory that the body is in
some ways like a magnet for energy.
It stores up energy and if you
don't push that energy out,
it starts freaking out. It doesn't
know what, at least my body. I mean my,
my only theories based on my personal
experiences and the way my body works is
if I don't exert energy in a
very powerful way, like um,
like a hard cardio,
like hard lifting,
running hills or something like that
where I like really blow it out.
If I don't do that several days a week,
I get these moments where I,
I know that like my body
wants to do something and it
wants to like overreact to
things, you know? And I feel like
that's what a lot of people say. Like,
oh that guy's got a bad temper.
I guarantee you a lot of what people
have is just, we call it a bad temper,
but a lot of his poor management of your
energy resources and that you haven't
blown out that energy and sort of this
way where your body is at an event.
It's not cause otherwise your body kind
of overflows with this excess stress,
anxiety or stress or energy.
And if you,
I forced myself just like I forced
myself to brush my teeth. I enjoy it.
I enjoy working out, but it's a, it's
an, I'm not getting away from it.
I have to do it because I don't
necessarily, I don't like,
it's not that I don't like
me when I'm not exercising,
but I don't like me as much
and I create more problems.
I create more problems
in my personal life.
I create more problems with
how I relate to people.
I create more problems when I'm,
when I'm just stressed and I've always
had this thing where I would
go long periods of time,
like I'll go a week without working
out just because I'm too fucking busy.
I can't do it, but I don't accept that
anymore. I've, over the last few years,
especially this last year,
I completely s that's now no longer
an option because I'm not at my best.
I'm not at my best as a human being.
I'm not at my best as a dad.
I'm not at my best as a father
or as a husband, rather.
I'm not at my best as a podcast or I'm
not at my best as a comedian and it can
be fixed. It's like something that can
be, it's not like I wish I could fly like,
no, I can work out. I can just, I can
just do it, you know? So I forced myself.
Now I get 100% absolutely. There's not a
week that goes by that I don't work out.
I make sure I get it in.
I just read a really interesting
article about sleep and there were,
it was a sleep study and they were saying
that they had put a bunch of people
that they'd done the test group of like
over like four weeks and they did a
group at at six hours a group at uh,
seven,
four hours in a group of eight hours.
And they found that like
if you slept eight hours,
you were exponentially, uh, more active.
And then they were saying there that
that's why Lebron James Sleeps like 11
hours at night.
Cause Cause I've had plantar fasciitis
with the feet so I had to like slow down
my running and I noticed
that I was getting like,
I was drinking more because I was
depressed because it was like this spiral.
And then one night I just,
I just didn't drink and I slept solid.
Like I slept like nine hours and my
feet felt good in the morning and I went
whoa,
I wonder if it,
and then I read this article and it says
that your body can't repair itself if
it doesn't get into the SMP,
sleep or something. Not the rem,
but the deep like lower your blood
pressure, lower your body temperature,
like get yourself out.
That's when the body starts repairing
itself and like you get sicker easily.
And I was like, so when I'm on the road
I'm doing these like quick turnarounds,
you do it late show Friday,
Thursday night and then you got,
or to show stores that it's Friday
night and you got press or whatever and
you're getting like six hours
sleep. You're not letting
your body repair itself.
So that's why your plantar
fasciitis comes in.
All these ailments that people have now,
it's like they got elements where it's
like nerve diseases where everyone was
just like, like just pain with, I
don't, I forget what it's called,
but I saw a commercial
on it and as I was like,
I guarantee you it's a lot of it has
to do with sleep. You're totally right.
Right.
Absolutely.
I noticed a big difference between also
sleeping all those hours in a row. Like,
sometimes I'll have to,
I'll have to do something early in the
morning and I'll get like four hours
sleep and then I'll take
a nap in the afternoon.
But it's not the same nurse still
backed up. It's not the same.
And you can't, you can't
recatch that deficit. There's,
that's the other thing they're saying
is that you can't like make up sleep.
So once you get it, you just missed it.
You just, it's done. It's gone forever.
It's like Kaiser San Jose. Well you can
get it, but you'd have to do, you know,
like they say it's like half time.
So like if you know you've missed
four hours sleep the night before,
he need an extra to the next nine
or something like that. Yeah.
But you sleep is a huge
essential. Tito Ortiz, when he was a
champion to sleep 12 hours a day. Yeah,
he's to toy. He's training
so much. You know,
he would go to bed and go to bed at
like midnight and wake up at noon.
Just sleep. God, yeah, we need it. You
need to recover. My kids sleep 12 hours
day. My kids sleep late. My
kids are like stoners now. Yeah.
They like wake up at like 1130 and they're
like, oh the fuck, what are we eating?
Well, it's summer right now, you know,
summertime for kids. It's fucking awesome.
I said to me that the night I'm putting,
I lose my like little loose cannon. She,
I'm putting her to bed. She goes,
can I talk to you for a second? Go.
She's like eight, eight this
weekend. Eight year old goes,
can I talk to you for a second? It's
such a weird moment. I go, yeah,
she was getting bad.
So I get in bed next to her and she
like posts up on her elbow and she goes,
right. Do you believe in time
travel? Whoa. And I'm like,
it's fucking real.
She came back from the future and talk
to herself and now she's got to clear it
with me. That's where
my brain's at. I'm like,
this is a great beginning to a great
movie. And so, so I was like, I do.
And she goes, do you think I could
come back to this time right now?
And I was like, what do
you mean? She's like,
if I go into the future and
make a time travel machine,
could I come back to here? I go, yeah.
She goes, what? I'd be this age. I go, no,
you'd be older. She goes, oh,
okay. That's it. And I was like,
what the fuck?
I wanted to get more into her head,
but you don't want to like
start picking it apart. So I go,
go to bed and I'm going ahead. I'm like,
I'm going out to the fucking man cave.
I'm pouring a cocktail and I'm fucking,
I was like,
that's because I'm
obsessed with time travel.
So that gives you an excuse to
pour a cocktail, start screaming.
You need start dreaming, man. A cocktail
is what you need to start dreaming.
I start when I, when I have a cocktail,
that first drink, it's like you're,
it's like a, it's like, it gets, it's
gets the juices going. You're like this.
Is that Ernest Hemingway moment,
the Ernest Hemingway? You,
do you really believe in time
travel? I do. In what way? Uh,
I believe that I believe
in a couple of things.
I believe that there are
parallel universes and all
over the planet and that you
can jump back and forth from those
parallel universes based on, um,
like I read this thing and I, and I'm
doing a poor example of explaining it,
but I believe there are
universities that I have died in,
but this is the one that
I'm living in right now.
And I think there will be times right,
die in this inner universe,
but I'll hop over other ones.
Does that make sense?
Should we just light a joint right
now? Yeah, I think you might have to.
I think this like what,
where is this coming from?
Like is one thing to have like a theory
like that could be possible and it
certainly could be. I mean just the
universe itself, it's so bizarre. Yeah.
There are hundreds of billions
of planets in this galaxy.
This is one of hundreds of billions of
galaxies in the known universe that this
universe might be a part of an infinite
number of universes because each black
hole has one half of 1%
of the mass of the galaxy.
It's a supermassive black hole,
and they believe that inside that
black hole is another universe.
That's where your time traveling
in those black holes could,
I just saw something online about it,
but I'm obsessed.
I'd like if you've seen time traveler's
wife. No. If I tell you about it,
I'll start crying. It's the greatest
movie ever. Does it like old yeller?
Because I cry when I see, oh yeller, it's
better. It's better as a comic is best.
I talked to Duncan about it one time
and he cried, but Dunkin but Dunkin,
so Dunkin,
like you can't bring half a subject to
Dunkin because he knows the rest of it.
He'll fill it up with Satan and he, I
go, it's the greatest movie in all rape.
He goes, you saw, you know Dunkin?
Yeah. Fallah movie. I go, yeah. He goes,
does he suck his own
Dick? Oh. And he goes,
then it's different than the book.
You read the book? He goes, yeah.
He goes back in time and teaches
himself to jack off. He does. It's like,
are you serious? And
don't get it. Like, yeah.
So he goes back in time and talks
to himself about jerking off.
Teaches himself how to it. I haven't
read the book or You saw the movie?
I don't know. We've got
a cold Tonkin. Oh God.
So he goes back in time
and sucks is on deck.
I Guess Duncan's one that gave me this
information that's not unnecessary.
I mean, Jesus Christ, all the shit
you can do if you had a time machine,
I'm going come back at Tom. Suck my
own dick. What really? How about yeah,
how about see a dinosaur? That's
what everybody would do. Right.
Um,
when you say
like that you believe in time travel,
do you think that time travel
is happening right now?
Do you believe that there is,
it's possible that someone could come
here right now and they could be from the
future?
I hope so. I hope so. I
believe that when you die,
you time travel for everyone else.
Like I think you keep living.
I don't believe in death. I believe
you keep living. Why do you think that?
Because I don't want to die.
I'm so obsessed with not
dying, but why do you see,
my thought is always that this life that
we've looked at from the moment we were
born, the breathing in and breathing
out the water in the ocean,
the trees that we've just come to accept
this as the only reality and that it's
very possible that whatever happens
when you die is just a spectacular but
completely different in
some in an unimaginable way.
And I get this from
psychedelic experiences that
I've had that seems so real,
but they're so different from anything
that you see in this life that it made me
reconsider this idea of what? What is
like the material life that we live?
What does this material world and is
this material world the only possibility
for an existence?
And I don't think it is.
I think this is just one possibility
out of an infinite number of potential
possibilities of how life could be.
I think this is just the life that we're
in right now. This is what life is,
but the idea of living this kind
of life over and over again, um,
I wouldn't say it's not appealing
because I love life. I have,
I'm having a great time.
I really enjoy it.
Some people get annoyed at you when you
say that because they haven't figured
life out or they don't.
I'm not,
not that I'm some sort of a master
in life that I've figured it out.
I'm better than you.
But what I'm saying is I figured out a
way to live a life that is very enjoyable
for me. I enjoy it and I enjoy
it because of a lot of things.
I enjoy it because I have great friends.
I enjoy it because I love
what I do for a living.
I enjoy it because I love my family.
I enjoy it because I, I just,
I just,
I have a passion for learning things and
I have a passion for just experiencing
things. There's so much to live
and experience in this life.
I'm enjoying the fuck out of it.
And the idea of this,
like one of the most terrifying things
for people is the idea of reincarnation
and not just the idea of death,
but the idea that you live the same life
over and over again. Well, I take it,
I have this again, I like this
slide. This life is great.
I wouldn't like age one
through 15 was rough,
really from 15 on things
started getting a lot better,
but still it's still,
it's still like anxiety filled,
fucking crazy disaster.
Well,
I mean I probably was deep
into my thirties before I
realized how to calm down
and actually enjoy life and not
just be like running on ice,
like hoping I don't fall, you know,
just wow, like barely been control,
but moving some album.
That's how I always felt.
And now I feel like I'm on solid
ground and I'm moving forward.
It's still completely unpredictable
and it's still, you know,
largely out of your control,
but the things that you can control,
you kind of understand those things.
But for a lot of people,
the idea of living this whole
life over and over and over again,
it's terrifying that it's pointless.
Oh, I told my dad the other day, I have,
I went through some drama back home with
friends where a friend passed and it
was really fucking hard. And my dad was
talking about death a lot and I was,
I got real surreal and I was like,
you know, I don't think, I mean like,
I think people would be sad at my funeral
by guarantee you a lot of people would
be like,
he did a lot more than we expected
with the minimum amount of
tools that God gave him.
He really milked the fuck out of
whatever bullshit he had. That's funny.
That's funny. Cause I want people to be
sad, but I want people to also go. I get,
you know who said it? I just
heard it, so, oh God damn it.
It was fucking Hixon Gracie. I was
listening to the podcast today. Yeah,
I'm about to quote Hicks.
He was here fuck.
Sitting in the seat an
hour ago and he said,
you feel like you're absorbing
his energy from that seat. Dude,
I saw the documentary choke.
He's a bad motherfucker.
Bad Ass fucking documentary
hits. Um, I in the,
and what really got me into Hickson was
cron cause I listened to the podcast
with Chron and he seemed very grounded.
He seemed very real going back to
the valley Tudo and he was like,
I'm going to do it.
And you just like,
and I didn't even know what that
was at the time I was there.
That's a really fascinating family.
I'd like to see a movie made
about their grandfather.
Oh yeah. Yeah. This Guy
Leo on my tee shirt,
he's, you know, his, his story stories.
Like he jumped in an ocean and rescue
people from sharks. I hung out.
Why? I told you about, you know,
I hung out with Horian that day and
Horian talked to about his grandpa,
his father,
a bunch like he challenged,
he got sent to jail and them came out of
the steps in Rio de Janeiro out of the
courthouse and challenge the guide the
guy's brother to a fight at the court
steps like this is like 1930 this
is just fucking, Rio de Janeiro
was insane and I've been to Rio.
So now you have like the real scope of
it and you meet Brazilians and all his
stories are so much better because the
way he says them with able to a zillion
accident and I put you in the grave, I
put you in the ditch. That's how it goes.
If you don't like it, cause these
guys don't know. Jews use it too.
I mean it's so fucking, it
was a great pocket. You know,
he had a philosophy on life.
Leo did a very specific philosophy.
He believed that you live this
life and if you do anything wrong,
if you do anything the wrong way,
you live the life over again.
You have to come back and do it
again. That was his thought. He did.
He said that Albert Brooks
Movie Groundhog Day. No,
no though heaven where Brooks goes to
heaven and every time they show him all
his mistakes in life. Do you ever saw
that? No, I don't think you did. Yeah,
that's not fucking whatever. Don't put up.
Um, don't pull it up. Don't pull it up.
It's all fucking bullshit.
Don't fucking pull it up.
Jamie. Jesus Christ. Jamie. Um,
but the, the idea behind that is scary
to a lot of people. You know that you,
you have to like,
when life presents you a scenario,
you have to pick the correct answer.
You have to do the correct thing,
have the correct behavior. That
was his thought. I this one of the,
one of the first times I ever actively
considered that possibility was reading
an interview with him where he
was talking about lists and he,
the way he says it,
he was an older man
and he was saying it in Portuguese and
they were translating it in English,
but he was saying that,
you know you, this is like,
he wasn't saying it like I think
maybe it could be possibly now.
He was just stating it as a fact that
you will live this life over and over
again until you get it right.
What a tough place to grow up in Brazil.
He was just this unbelievable stud.
I'm just an incredible bad motherfucker
and not like a physically imposing man.
He was 130 540 pounds,
small guy,
like maybe one 47 like at his heaviest.
He wasn't big by any stretch of the
imagination. It wasn't physically strong,
wasn't some kind of freak athlete,
wasn't particularly flexible,
just smart as fuck. Toughest Shit.
Just figured out how to, first of all,
never had sex unless it was
for procreation. Came in,
every girl he ever had sex with, he had
like 19 kids and I'm not bullshitting.
He had a ton of kids and
all of them killers. He, me,
he raised the greatest fighters the
martial arts world has ever known.
If you want to talk about a family,
there's never been a family that
can fuck with the grace. He's,
it's not even a close second.
It's like,
what's the greatest martial arts
family of all time? The Gracies,
everybody would say that.
And it's directly, the
shamrock has tried to do that.
Right? Well, they tried to name all
the kids they adopted shamrock. Yeah.
But that's, you know, that's,
that's the take on it. First of all,
it's that Bob Shamrock was a,
just a great guy who took in a lot of
kids that had troubled pasts and he would
take a lot of them in when
they were in their 19, 18,
20, you know, and adopt them.
You know, we take them as they were
older, they were already troubled
kids like frank shamrock, um, went
into great depth about it. Like,
you know who he's really troubled and
had all sorts of legal problems and
everything.
When,
when Bob took him in and he changed
his name to shamrock and then, uh,
Ken Shamrock, of course, same
thing, you know, so Bob Shamrock,
the guy who did that was just a,
a really great guy who taught those
young men how to be a man. You know,
that's important. Oh, without
a doubt. Hugely a fort,
but very different than what Leo did.
Leo just made an army with his dick.
He like created an army, like all
these people that were born out of his,
his procreation, they became these
killers. He's killer fighters.
And he was basically starting a franchise.
His Dna,
he started at Jujitsu franchise like
Robert Hartman did with the Improv.
In a way that's almost impossible
to replicate today unless you,
they fucking sociopath.
I mean,
you could kind of only do this and
in 1940 just shoot loads and checks.
And he was the Johnny Appleseed
of Fugitsu by just sweet.
Now does hoists and Horian and Hickson
had the same moms? That's a good question.
Some of them do not.
Have the same moms.
I do not believe that hoists
and Hicks and have the same mom.
I think they have different moms. There's
a bunch of moms in the picture and he,
I would love to grab a book,
just married, not married.
I don't know what you're talking
about. I'm fucking, I'm fucking,
I'm making babies. And his,
his thing is like, you know,
he would talk about it every time I would
have sex is for procreation. Like he,
he wasn't having recreational sex.
He was trying to make babies
different story maybe.
But he was such a gangster man.
He was so interesting.
I had a Steve Maxwell on the podcast
before and Steve Maxwell when he was,
uh, before he was even a Blackbaud,
I believe he's a brown belt.
He was a training with
hoists and he went to stay,
stayed for a couple months at Elios
farm in Brazil. And Leo would,
uh,
you know,
he had cows and goats and he would milk
the goats and they would make cheese
with the, with the goat milk. It
was all raw, unpasteurized cheese.
He would grow his own vegetables.
He had like a way of living that was
like really like close to nature.
Like he didn't believe in preservatives.
He didn't believe in
antibiotics for animals and
like everything that he ate was
like stuff that he grew and did
everything like in a very natural way.
Fascinating. It makes you feel like a
bitch and you hear about a guy like that.
He's just the guy just,
I mean I'm still jacking off.
Think about all the Times you've
pulled out your life. How about him?
Never just fucking roaring into
the abyss with his calm far
more babies. Bring them to me. I will
raise them and turn them into an army.
I, I'm impressed by the challenging
people like the Hixson does.
Like they challenged people to a
fight and they go, I challenge you to,
if I haven't challenged anybody to shit,
well that's probably good.
In this day and age it doesn't
really work. It's like,
you know, challenge someone to erase and
all that's invented as bicycles, right?
Today they have a thing called cars
are going to lose it. Fucking race.
Volume was a bike. I'm going to race
you and the guy blows by you on a car.
Like you challenge people to fights
and they're gonna fucking stab you.
Someone's going to shoot you. It's not,
it's a different world that we live in.
I mean it was a different
world in Hickson's time.
You heard the stories that he was telling
about people showing up to fights with
guns and knives and shit.
But I think what Leo was doing,
W it was such a wild time like
living in Brazil at that time,
completely different era,
you know,
completely different time as far as
martial arts too. It was almost unknown.
Like the, the, the,
the reality of martial arts at
that time was essentially Asian.
It was all Asian influenced.
It was Japanese, it was
karate and it was Kung Fu.
And then there was,
uh,
India had some wrestling and then there's
Iran had wrestling. There was some, uh,
different cultures that
had grappling arts.
But essentially all of
it was coming from Asia.
There was nothing in South America,
there was nothing in a, in North America,
there was boxing, you know, people had
to hand techniques. And some wrestling,
but the,
what they had started and what his family
had started was a revolution changed
martial arts from that seed,
the seed that was planted by my Ada,
by this, uh, this guy that had
come to, um, to Japan to teach,
he came from, uh, from
Japan to Brazil to teach he,
he planted seeds and these Brazilian
people that spread across the entire world
within a hundred years,
I mean less than 100 years later,
martial arts have evolved
more substantially than they
have in the last thousand.
It's really the last 20 years from the
time Americans found out about it from 93
on from 93 on is that
when Jujitsu showed up,
that's when Jujitsu showed up in the form
of the ultimate fighting championship.
That's when we saw funny hoists,
Gracie,
because we were taking a long
time for it to take root.
Mike Larosa was like group one of my
friends who is from Saudi Arabia like you,
but he grew up in Saudi Arabia,
but it's that I think worked for
coke or something or you know,
he had a job over there and he came
back to the states and he was in eighth
grade and I met him in like seventh grade,
eighth grade.
And he would learn Jujitsu
in Saudi Arabia. Whoa.
And he was talking about Jujitsu and I
remember that's the first time I ever
heard about it. So not your Rabia. Wow.
Yeah. I wish I can get in touch with him.
Callen grew up overseas like that.
You know,
my cousin hung out with you the
other night. My fucking cousin.
Because your cousin, big tall kid.
Like with like a ginger hair. You,
you hung out with you and cal. He's
friends with Callan. Andrew Hobson.
Where was this at the Improv,
like you guys were all hanging out and my
cousin's like, go. I met Joe and I said,
Oh really? Did you tell him you're
my cousin? And he's like, ah,
like a lot of thought when you do that.
He's like, I don't know. I said, well,
what did you say goes well,
I like you. After he left,
it was Kim and Callan and he said, yeah,
I think my cousin is friends with Joe.
And Callen goes, who's your cousin?
He goes, Burke, Chrysler Gallegos.
Your guns is burned. You
haven't even brought that up.
Yeah, that's a weird thing.
Not Blowing up at a comedy club. He's
been hanging out with Kalyn like weeks.
He's never mentioned that he's my cousin
because fucking socially retarded.
How did he hang out? Why is he hanging
out with Callan? What's going on?
I have no idea.
He's like a screen.
He's a writer and he's trying to put
something together for Kalyn and so a,
and so they, I don't know, you know Khalil
is like a good guy. So he's like, Hey,
come hang out with a beer. We'll watch
the fight or whatever. And that counts.
Like come down,
we're doing comedy juice and then you
and him are all hanging out. I go, Andy,
Andrew, you're in a moment. We could just
simply make things very casual and say,
hey my cousin's Bert Kreischer and you
would've just been like, oh how cool.
And that's it. He would have never
leveraged it by go fucking bring it up.
He goes,
oh and then maybe next time maybe he's
like I'm tired of being bird crushed.
His cousins want to be
much so would it be me man,
this is fucking bullshit.
Part living limiting your fucking shadow.
It's just interesting the
way people carry themselves.
Cause I'm the first
person like that if like,
like if I ran into Eddie
probably on the street, I was,
first of all I was like I it's Bert Cause
I never think anyone remembers my name
by be like it has Bert.
I'm friends with Joe.
Like I would connect the tissue right
away. Yeah, that's probably the best way.
But then if you've done that,
never have someone do that and then you
bring it up to the person and they go,
I don't know that fucking dude.
That's weird.
When someone like becomes really friendly
with you under false pretenses that it
finds you find out they don't really
know that person. Yeah. That's awkward.
Really.
All I was afraid that I was afraid when
I was met Hixon that saying that I had,
I had roll,
I'd world round with his brother.
I didn't know if they were friends or not.
They have issues.
I was fucking nervous saying that
I'm an idiot. No, it's not an,
you're not an idiot at
all. No big deal. I mean,
just because they have issues doesn't
mean you have to have issues with them,
but why can't I just be confident
enough to go, hi, my name's Bert.
It's very nice to meet you because you
wanted to tell a story and you know, be,
you know, I've had some experiences
with Jujitsu. Yeah. As an untrained God,
that was unhurt Burt, right? Yeah.
That was the craziest fucking shall,
I couldn't believe what
you did on that show.
I'm glad you didn't get totally hurt.
I got what God did.
I broke my ribs and broke my foot.
Yeah, but you're alive. Yeah. Yeah.
I'm glad I'm alive.
Totally hurt is dead cause there's a lot
of fucking shows where you could easily
get totally hurt. Yeah, I could, I,
I could have really gotten fucked up,
but thank God I didn't.
I W I w I mean I I the thing I was
telling some about it the other day,
the thing that was crazy about doing that
show was that like we technically shot
a porn one day. Really? Oh
yeah. Like no questions asked.
They sent me to a Dominatrix camp and
they sent me to a dominatrix and then I
was the gimp. So like I was
tortured for like, not even like,
not even like 30 minutes for like
five hours. Dude, they bring me in
for folks only listening. He just said,
dude. And then he scooted his chair back,
put his hands on the rest and
adjusted himself. Here we go.
I they show the whole premise was,
I didn't know what I was going to do,
but I was walking a mile in another
man's shoes. So I show up to,
this place is on,
it's like downtown by the Ralphs downtown.
If you take six all the way down, it's
like I'm in a mansion down there. Right.
But right in that area, a downtown
mansion, it was a huge fucking house.
I didn't even know they had
mansions downtown, old school.
That's where la started. Really?
Yeah, yeah, yeah. If you,
La is an interesting town because it
downtown was where everything started.
So the further out you go is the
expanse of the expanse of La.
And then they'd make a leap to the beach.
So the connective tissue from the beach
to downtown and hey, Brian, shut the door.
Did. And so, um, so anyway, so
they, they take me to this mansion,
I'm in the van and then
this dude comes out,
turn that switch,
turn that light on.
This dude comes out with a blindfold
and he's like, put this on.
So I put it on and then two girls
grabbed me by both arms and like walk me
through a mansion and I'm walking
through this like downstairs,
upstairs up these stairs. And then
I can feel the lights up, a room on,
like I can feel the energy change.
So I go and I sit in a, in a,
in a gynecological exam table but it's
steel and as I sit they start taking my
pants off. They take my shirt
off. I'm like, I don't want
to her. And they're like,
don't worry, you won't need it.
Totally naked. Totally naked worry.
You won't need it. Totally
naked. Me Up my arms first,
then my legs.
Then they take the blindfold off and is
this chick mistress Isabella and she is
in straight up latex outfit with her tits
billing out a zipper on her vagina and
she has a cattle prod.
She's like,
today you're going to be a gap and just
prods me in the balls and I'm like, God.
I'm like, ah. And the cal probably
electrical like electrical prod,
like not like not, not in a cat. I'm,
I'm using large terms to express the the
event but like not like a like that now
but like electric shock,
like boutique and shocks.
My balls like blank and I'm like,
and we are producers allowed
all this to take place.
My producers were sitting on
apple boxes in front of me.
They're all sitting on our boxes with
camera men that are sitting on tripods.
They've got lights all
over around Marnie Hochman,
the executive at the time
for Fox is sitting there too,
and for like three hours and they
put five pound weights on my balls.
They fucking pounds, nipple clamps
with weights on the nipple clamps,
candle wax. And it won't, what? Go ahead.
Pop five pounds. They work up to that.
They can put a one pounder
and then, uh, they put,
they put this thing around your balls
that looks like a bracelet. It's,
it looked just like this. They put her
on your balls like this. And then the,
and it's got two sides,
like Hasidic Jewish is
ringlets that are chains.
And then they put a weight
on it just holds them down.
It didn't actually hurt that bad, but
uh, then the lady said, all right,
are you ready? Would you
rather the speculum? And I
was like, next. She's like,
or the sounds. And I was like, oh,
the sound's so she brings meaning open
your asshole. I'm sorry. Any speculation,
I'm guessing. Yeah. So she puts,
opens the this leather briefcase and
there's different like steel rods that are
look like look like this thin,
they're like this and the summer,
different shaped and I was like,
I want the sounds,
I don't even know what that has been.
It looks like harmonic tuning forks that
you'd hit and go boom and then put by
my balls and I'd be like,
and she goes, all right, he
wants to sounds lube them up.
I go lube them up. Where do you,
where do you put them? She goes, we,
we put them in your urethra.
And I was like, oh I go,
why the fuck do you call them the sounds
then and not dick sticks or something
else. She goes cause each one makes
you make a different sound. I was,
oh that's not sounds and I was done.
It's not sounds,
if you have to make them yourself,
that's like going to a hamburger place.
They go, all right. Did you bring your own
beef? Like what was the hamburger place?
The fuck, you don't sell hamburgers,
the sounds you make your own sounds.
She's going to play me like an instrument.
So you did this for how long? I,
probably four hours and
then we went downstairs.
She was actually pretty cool and she was
pretty hot. Hot, like pretty hot six.
Uh, I'm gonna say I'm gonna
say hard seven low eight.
[inaudible] seven [inaudible] seven like,
like she like a definite set.
It's hard to judge because
she was in lay tech,
so anyone in latex automatically
it's like a six. But,
but she had a really pretty face,
but she had like the, you know,
the kind of face where you're like,
I'm attracted to it,
but it's not like my ideal.
Okay.
Like the kind of chick that if
she's a librarian you'd fuck her.
But if she worked as a Hooters waitress
and you're like, Eh, you know what I mean?
Google or Google or Mr Bella.
No, no, no. But you can see
what she looks like. She's,
I don't want to give her any press.
He's out there needle and
people and putting fucking
sounds and their dick. Yeah.
She was like, this one
dude came out and like, uh,
it looked like he got done
in the gym. Okay. He had like
a bag on and he was like,
look like you get cleaned up and
he just gotten out of the gym.
I think that's the only
way I can express it.
Became out of this door from ups
downstairs. I go, who is he? She goes, oh,
well I'll see you later. And he's
like, bye. Thank you. She's like,
he's been down there for the weekend.
I was like, what? And she's like, yeah,
some people pay to stay down there. And
I tortured them throughout the weekend.
Oh God. And I was like, really?
And then the whole, all right,
pull a picture of this bitch up I need,
his mistress is a Bella and I say
bitch with all love and respect, she's,
I'm sure she'd want the press
of people buying or videos.
What if she's still doing it?
I'll never forget that name though.
Mr and she had hurt her assistant was
this Asian chick who was hot as fuck.
This is the best part of the whole
thing is at the very beginning,
they look at my dick and
it's so small and she looks,
yells back to the Asian shake. She goes,
we're working with a blood cock. I go,
what? She goes, we're working with a
blood cock. I go, you're talking to me?
She goes, yeah, you're, you have a blood
cock. What does that mean? I go, exactly.
I'm like, what? What? As opposed
to, and I'm like, is there,
do I have a venereal disease? Like
something going on? She goes, no, no, no.
There's Meat Cox and there's blood Cox.
You have a blood cock.
It means that when blood shows up
to your cock, it then looks good,
but until that blood's there, it doesn't
look any good. When you have a meat cock,
you have a lot of meat on your cock
and then very little room for blood.
So guys that have big Dick soft or meet
Cox, she's hot. It's fucked dude. Yup.
That's her. That looks like her. Yeah.
That really looks like her mistress
Isabella. Is She in la? Yeah.
She's beautiful. Yeah. She's, she's not
a seven. My balls were getting tortured.
I don't fucking remember perfectly.
Maybe this is just like a really
good picture of it. But that, yeah,
that does look like her cause she
has like a, yeah, she's pretty hot.
That's pretty hot. I wouldn't
say that. I'd say that.
It's like at least that picture,
the picture that I'm looking
at going back to the other,
she gave me a bunch of videos.
I have videos of what it was
back when you go to that.
I mean I have a blank screen
VCR. She gave me a bunch of VCRs
of like dominatrix stuff, man.
Some of the shit was so hot. VCR
tapes of dominatrix stuff. Yeah.
This is before you could like get
online and have quick Internet to watch
whatever the fuck you want.
So like do you mean you've always
had fast internet but like,
but like there was a very big
period of time up until like,
I want to say like 2004 that like
downloading porn just took forever.
Unless you had like Dsl
and this was before then.
This is probably 2001 and so 2002 and so
she gave me a bunch of BCR. She's like,
cause she did one thing that really
turned me on and I was like, Whoa,
what the fuck was that?
And then,
and then I regressed in the middle of
all this torturing and I remember the
first thing I ever saw sexually was
that a new stand and it was dom,
it was a girl's tied up
when I was like first grade.
So first thing I ever saw
and I went, whew, she was,
we'll check these videos out,
see if you like them. And like I
wish I still had one of the videos.
So she did something to you while you
were in the middle of being tortured.
He did like, well you just
fucking hit it. Whatever it is.
I said, marshmallow, safe word
marshmallow. Give me the fuck Outta here.
I don't want to blow a load in front
of everybody. Wow. Is that good? Yeah,
it was with latex and
she had me bound like,
like you were sending a package to
somebody and she was and I was like,
and I get,
see what I want. If I was going
to talk to a woman like that,
I would want to know what she
does in her personal life.
Like this is like your job,
like you like super normal,
you know like
they're usually submissive when their
mistress in their personal life. Yeah.
At least all the people that I know
a lot of those guys because at my ex
girlfriend and all of
them like spank beat.
I know this one girl that would go up
to San Francisco and get her ass kicked
by, a guy would pay her money just to get
her ass kicked and just come back like
thousands of dollars.
But usually in real life stop or
pay her money to get her asking.
What do you mean there's
the whole community's really
fucked up. Like there's,
there's mistresses and the are,
there's guys that do it all.
So the guys are creepy. Guys
are creepy as you saying. No,
the guy would beat her up. The guy would
pretty much beat her up, like what would,
what we would think is beating up.
But to her it was called a fetish.
It would be like spanking,
beating.
You would have electrical prods that
you would like electrocute the person.
She would come back black and blue
every time he would pay her. Yeah.
And then she got off
show up and he got off on beating her.
Yes. Oh, I wouldn't trust to do that.
I would think that that guy is
going to take it too far. Yeah.
Get his credit card number first.
That's not enough.
Your Dad, you going to fucking use it
on amazon.com fuck you. I'm a ghost.
I'm ordering Shit Online.
Nature box.
I don't know why,
but for me it's one thing like if a dude
likes to get tied up and beat up by a
check,
that's as disturbing as
a guy who wants to beat a
checkup. The Dai, the guy,
a guy wanting to bt checkup is fucking,
that's dangerous to me. That's scary.
Don't chew in front of a
microphone burden. It's just
weird. I can't help it, man.
You got me on these fucking,
just push the microphone aside or
don't eat while the podcast is on.
It's only a couple hours, buddy. You can
get through it. I know you can do it.
You're strong. You're strong.
Bert. Kreischer yeah, I
don't know. I don't deal.
There's some really bums me out about a
guy that wants a beat up a check. Yeah.
Well this is, I mean Panger well yeah, at
least he's going about it the right way.
Is it? I mean really. I mean, I don't
know man. It makes me think of like,
what was it? Was it seven? Was it
the movie? Psycho American psycho.
That's what it was.
Yeah.
American psycho where he would do fucked
up shit to them and then pay them and
then he ran into the girl on
the street and she's like,
no, get away. He's like it.
He's going to,
I would love for you.
I would love for you to get a high
end prostituting here like the girl,
but just to hear her stories of like,
I guarantee you she's got some fucked up
stories. This is not about that though.
When you get a high end prostitute,
you don't hear stories, just fuck them.
Jesus Christ, we, me and
my buddy Eddie saw this,
I mean the hottest chick I've ever seen
in my life in Vegas where we're just
walking around and this girl comes up,
she's like, if you guys want to party.
And I remember thinking,
not knowing she was a prostitute,
the hottest girl I've
ever seen in my life.
And I was like 10 10 no questions asked,
10 after a car accident,
10 in a softball uniform. And I was
like, well, I was like, fuck yeah.
And she was like 1500 bucks an hour,
like 1500 like I remember going,
how good is that?
It's gotta be amazing for stupid rich
billionaire dude who 15 I mean if you have
$1 billion, what's 1500 bucks?
It's like 50 bucks to you.
Probably not even five bucks.
Five bucks to you.
What do you think the market price,
the fair market portrayed pipes for
Pocius what do you want to know?
I think that if you're
getting like a streetwalker,
you got one thing and then I can get
up to like several thousand dollars.
There was a woman who used to,
uh,
there was a website and it got brought
up on my message board and bunch of dudes
got so mean with her. It's just, I
felt real bad because, uh, they were,
they were like going back and forth with
her and I think she even signed up on
my message board,
but it was some insane amount of money
was like $6,000 an hour or something like
that.
Maybe $6,000 a day or $3,000 an hour or
you could do the whole evening for six
grand or something like that.
But it's a lot of money. And um,
a lot of them have websites and they,
you know,
they will like talk about themselves and
these very flattering and glowing terms
and talk about their interest and
all that. And you're like, yeah,
but you're a prostitute. Like if, if
all these things were awesome about you,
why would you be a prostitute?
That's the weird thing about prostitutes.
Like this guy had a
real interesting point.
I was watching this ted
video the other day,
we were just talking about prostitutes.
Yeah,
I was talking about prostitutes and he
was always talking about pornography and
like what's negative about pornography?
And one of the things was
talking about was like
this social exile aspect
of it that like say if you,
okay,
like here's the perfect example.
I would invite you over to my house
anytime you want to come over and have
dinner and you've been over my house
before for my kids' parties and shit.
You're a good friend.
But if you told me that you
had been to a prostitute, um,
it wouldn't affect me at all. Like
I wouldn't, I wouldn't go, oh,
fucking birds never coming over
my house again. That's sick. Fuck.
Of course a w over.
But if you had been a prostitute,
I would never have you over.
And the well he was saying is we will
sit down with people that have been to
brothels and we have no reservations.
Like people who have been to brothels
several times. We'll laugh it off.
But you don't sit down
with prostitutes when you,
when a person actually pays for sex,
that's one thing.
But when a person gets paid for sex,
especially a woman,
like we put them in this like very
undesirable social outcast category.
Yeah. So I mean, you
know, Molly crab apple,
she's a artist who was on the podcast.
One's very talented art.
It's a very interesting thinker too.
She's very, very smart woman. And um, uh,
she, she has friends that are a
sex workers, you know, and she's,
she doesn't see anything wrong with it.
You know,
her attitude is what's the big
deal? It's just sex, you know,
that's what they do and they have a good
time and they liked their clients and
you know, she has friends who
do it and you could see it
that way. I could, I mean,
she obviously did and she's very
intelligent. But I think for most of us,
that's not how we see it.
We put people in a category and that's
like a forbidden thing to do. Right?
I mean,
when you agree,
there's definitely different
kinds of prostitutes.
Like I back in the day before I even knew
one, I would, I would think that also,
but nowadays with these
porn, uh, prostitutes, like
there's a website that don't,
I won't say,
but it's all the high end prostitutes
that are in porn and you can sit there and
and pick which one you want
and then you have to send,
you have to go to the doctor,
you have to get tested.
You have to send your reports to them.
You have to give your driver's license,
your credit card you have there,
they would do it.
They're going to do a full background
check. Once all this happens,
then you get like approved.
But every time you want a new prostitute,
if it's after 30 days, just like a porn
star, you have to get retested again,
send them, send the information.
But these are high end people.
These are presidents of companies.
These girls are like anywhere from
two to $6,000 but it that come to me,
it's like, okay, this is just like
porn. You're just doing porn now.
This is the person's been tested,
background check, blah blah, blah.
You're doing it maybe once a
month to get an extra $6,000.
I can see that a little bit more
than like somebody that's like, Hey,
I have a room at the motel six,
I'm going to be here all day in and out.
That to me that's disgusting. That's
like a, that's like a horrible,
that's like what I think a prostitute is.
Well a lot of them was just like when
they're that it's just drug addicts that
are making poor decisions because they
have to take chances because they need to
get their fix. Well you're talking
about is like a slick escort situation,
which yeah,
for the girl probably definitely better.
And for the guy probably better too.
And it's way better than
porn if you think it.
Cause I mean like these people
are presidents of companies,
they've been tested and everything. No
one knows about it. We're like pig a pig.
Oh about it.
They have a database,
you know about credit cards and
they told you, right, well why?
What meaning like a doctor,
they get tested for STDs.
Right. But what I'm saying is it's not
advertised for the whole road to be like,
oh look at this person's butthole and
pussy and they're getting fucked by this
guy. You know, it's like you don't get
to see it. So I see what you're saying.
It's a little different. It's weird.
Well look, my, my stance on it of course
is it, everything should be
illegal. I mean I think if
you want to get your balls,
cattle prodded and you know, you want
to get beat up by some dominatrix,
of course it should be illegal.
Obviously. I, I have more of a problem,
like I said with a woman
getting beat up. I just, my,
my core, my DNA, here's that. I just
go like that. That, I don't know,
cause I feel like a guy that would
want to beat the shit out of a woman.
Like I don't like it.
There's something deep seated. There's
something dirty inside that not just dirty
like I,
I think they're dangerous.
Like a woman is physically weaker
than a man. Like did the display,
like it makes more sense to me that a
man would want to get beat up by a woman
because it's, it's not, you have to give
into her to do that. Like you could just,
she could hit you too hard and you'd be
like, bitch, what the fuck did you just,
you know, like it would change
the whole thing. But these guys,
a lot of them that are these
dominatrix, um, clients,
they're um,
they're like really powerful people who
are in these positions where they run
companies and they have all these people
that listened to them and they have to
be buttoned down all day and they
were in ties and shit and never speak.
And they'd get there. Yes, mistress.
Yes, mistress and the you kiss my foot,
you piece of shit. Yeah. This
mistress, like they like that.
It's like a free release to them and the
chick beats him up and kicks him in the
balls and shit. Like it doesn't bother
me. I mean, maybe it's hypocritical.
Maybe I'm now minded in my thinking,
but I fuck,
I got a real problem with a guy
wants to beat the shit out of check.
I think you, I think a lot of us
do. It's really fucked up too.
But the guy that I'm talking about,
the supposedly,
I mean I know a couple of people
that used to do this and, and the,
it would be like dentist's chair
in a room like dark, like Dexter.
They get tied up and then
just like different things.
You pull out his like little tools and
the whole time just like fucking sitting
there with a hard on with her.
No one
that's a bunch of bad life decision.
How many of those girls one up getting
killed and they must happen. It must.
It must.
I mean how many girls
killed every year by Johns?
I mean it must happen.
Do you remember that guy in Vancouver?
Not Vancouver.
Was a outside of Vancouver somewhere.
BC who is a serial killer who
killing prostitutes and feeding them.
Knew his pigs.
I heard pigs leave fucking anything.
Yeah, they'll eat anything. Yeah.
There was that movie snatch.
Right. What movie is that? Yeah,
that's where I learned it. Dammit.
Fuck can say something like,
I learned it and then I'm like, Oh,
you learned that all the real world.
You fucking say some real
deep philosophical shit
and turns out puck said it
first.
I can't believe we're sober.
Hey man,
we can be funny sober and have
fun sober that. Yeah, I've uh,
I don't know what I was saying, but
yeah, I'm fucking an idiot. Pigs,
pigs and prostitutes. Pigs. Yeah.
Yeah. Pigs are fucking voracious
eaters, man. They're ruthless. They, uh,
they would just run through bodies. They,
you know, you throw a body in there.
If anything, you know, any
kind of an animal, they just
eat, they'll eat everything.
They'll eat everything.
The only thing you're supposed to do,
if you try to get rid of a body
and you throw it in a pig pen,
is he supposed to smash the teeth?
Cause they'll, they won't, uh,
they won't eat the teeth. Totally.
Really let him down. Yeah.
The teeth will come out whole and then
you have dental records and shit like
that mother fucker you need,
he's like a hardcore coffee
grinder and you throw the tea.
Oh, make it shut up. I'm Vitamix.
Oh yeah. Tech. You ever
seen a BLENDTEC blender?
Fucking iPhone.
You should try teeth next time.
So I knew what I wanted to talk to
you about. Bulletproof coffee. Okay.
So I'm sitting with my dad
in Tampa. He's like, buddy,
I'm going to give you the best coffee
I've ever had. I was like, what?
And he's like me and Bartol level of him.
It's his best friend I go to. He goes,
bulletproof coffee, you're going to
fucking love it. But he's not doing,
he's not getting bulletproof coffee. He's
just using organic coffee. That's fine.
And then doing the mix. Well, you
know, that's fine, right? Yeah.
But I feel bad cause there's a bullet
proof of his steed. ASPREY, Dave Asprey.
Don't feel bad because,
let me explain to you all the fallout.
I don't know if you've paid attention
to what happened. No. Um, okay.
The original idea of mixing up and
bulletproof executive is Dave Asprey's
company and he has bulletproof this and
bulletproof that and it's like sort of a
marketing labeling thing. Yeah. So
he called it bulletproof coffee.
It was actually invented by a guy named
Rob Wolf and Robb Wolf came up with it a
long time ago and wrote about it,
about mixing MCT oil and butter in coffee.
Now real quick,
MCT oil is medium
chain triglyceride oil and what it is
is they take the most nutritious aspects
of coconut oil and some
different kinds of oil.
They spin them in a centrifuge
and they take out this,
I'm just using coconut oil.
Coconut oil is fine. Okay.
Coconut oil is a very good
for virgin or reverse margin.
Now you don't want to if you
want raw raw coconut on. Yeah,
it's very good for you. Yeah. Um, anyway,
so what Aspery was telling us was
that his coffee was uniquely free of
Mycotoxins and that mycotoxins
where we give people headaches,
mycotoxins would cause you to crash.
All these,
all these different things he was
attributing to microtoxins and he was even
saying that point being, here's
the point, he had no tests.
He wasn't showing us anything like,
like he was saying that all these
different coffees of Mycotoxin,
it's a real issue.
No one talks about it,
but when you start
reading about it online,
I found out that this
wasn't an issue at all.
Like it wasn't something that people
talking about that were involved in the
coffee world. Like there had been
mycotoxin issues in the past,
but they figured out a bunch of
different way, cold or wet processing,
a bunch of different ways to deal
with coffee. See all coffee. This is,
I found this because I had a peer Giuliani
on the podcast who is a coffee expert
relation to Rudy. Fascinating
guy. No, I think that's his name.
Make sure that's this right named Peter
Giuliani. I want to, I don't want to, or
I've been to many conversations with
Todd Carmichael's on travel channel.
He does. Uh, he does.
He's a coffee expert.
He does like dangerous grounds
is the name of the show.
Peter Juliano. That's his name
if Tyree. Very good guy. Anyway,
so all coffee comes from
Ethiopia, all of it. All of it.
Every coffee that's ever been made
outside of Ethiopia was originally in
Ethiopia and then they took it
somewhere else and grew coffee there.
So whether it's, I thought all coffee
came from Colombia. Yeah, me too.
I thought it was like South American
cause you always hear about Colombian
coffee and that fucking Juan
manwell. What's his name? One one,
you know Juan Valdez? Juan, is that
right? Was his fucking donkey. Well No,
it's a black guy picking coffee
in Ethiopia. It's an Ethiopian,
this thousands of different
strains in Ethiopia and maybe,
I think he said three to five elsewhere.
It's crazy.
Wow. All coffee comes from Ethiopia. Okay,
okay. Maybe it's more than three to five,
but it's a s a minuscule percentage.
I don't remember the exact numbers.
Um, so be calm. Ethiopia
is a very dry climate.
It's a very,
very unique in that respect.
When they were taking coffee
other places and growing it,
they were dealing with moisture.
They were dealing with mold that was
growing and it took them a while to figure
out that this is bad. They still
have coffee, rust is still an issue.
But what he was saying,
what asked me,
we were saying with no evidence
whatsoever was that there was all these
mycotoxin infected coffee everywhere you
look like a Starbucks and coffee bean,
it was all bad for you.
So we wound up doing tests.
First Tate did a caveman coffee, tested
their coffee and um, Asprey's coffee,
their coffee,
which is single estate plan from Colombia,
turned out to have no
mycotoxins in it whatsoever.
It was all done co with wet processing
for coffee according to Tate,
had below threshold levels,
which means it's not significant of
two different types of mycotoxins.
So that meant that his process,
whatever his process was, didn't,
wasn't completely eliminating it,
but it was nothing where you
had to consider what it's,
it's such a minuscule amount.
There's not dangerous to your body.
So that gave us a red flag. So we
were like, well, what the fuck?
So we start looking into it because
we had been parodying what he had been
saying about Michael [inaudible].
I had been, I should. Yeah.
So then we wound up spending
a lot of money on these tests.
We tested four different types of
coffee for a broad spectrum of uh,
mycotoxins. None of them had any in it,
so he was saying like 75% of all coffee,
mycotoxins in it, but his coffee is
uniquely, it's not true. It's just,
it's just simply not true.
So he was benefiting from this and it
left me with a real moral dilemma as one
of the owners of on it. Um,
should we still sell this coffee?
Ultimately I decided I still drink it.
So there's nothing wrong with the coffee,
but if you go into on its website,
you won't see any of that
bullshit about mycotoxins anymore.
What it is is good single
source coffee and that's it.
Any unique fucking method that he has of
eliminating mycotoxins is not only not
necessary,
it's unique only to him and not to the
entire rest of the fucking multibillion
dollar coffee world. Like they know
how to take care of that shit. It's,
it's hooey. That's what it is. So if your
dad's using organic coffee, good coffee,
I'm sure it's fine. And if it
wasn't fine, you would know.
And not only that Doctor Rhonda Patrick
said that small levels of mycotoxins
actually,
they elicit a compensatory response from
your body that can even be beneficial.
Really.
I remember when you were saying like I,
the thing that made me kind of go,
well that doesn't seem right.
When I kept on going like,
when are you going to test Starbucks?
And he's like, oh, it's really expensive.
And it's not a thousand bucks across,
just like, you know, 4,000 bucks to test.
But that would be a good test to have
if you had a company like am I spend a
$2,000 so I can say Starbucks had it and
you don't get anything Starbucks, right.
Test. They're fucking coffee.
You know? It's just, it's,
it's really fucked up. Look,
he is said in the past that he had
aspergers then he cured it with his
bulletproof diet.
I suspect he has not cured it.
We're dealing with a bit of a
social issue here. It's not just,
and he got famous from doing this stuff
and being on our podcast introduced him
to millions,
literally millions of people,
and I feel real responsible in that way
because a lot of people like you were
about to pair it,
that your dad was doing it all wrong
because your dad was getting his coffee.
It wasn't Michael Toxin
free. Guess what? Oh,
coffee essentially is fucking mycotoxins,
mycotoxins rail.
But there's mycotoxins in everything.
There's mycotoxins in human breast milk.
There's micro toxins in porn. Hi Britt,
you out. Let's not talk about that.
We're going again. But there's, it's
not the issue that he made it out to be.
Not only that,
he also said something that
I also should've fucking
chase down on him. He said,
his coffees you need gives you
an unique cognitive benefits.
There's no mechanism in your coffee
that uniquely makes you smarter.
It doesn't exist. It's just
coffee. You're, it's not,
there's nothing special.
It's not a genetically modified being
from Mars that makes you fucking brain
grow when you drink a cup of Java.
It's just fucking coffee.
Does caffeine have cognitive benefits?
Yes, it does. Yes it does. Yes it does.
It has been proven.
These things are proven.
Does caffeine or those coffee have
antioxidant effects? Yes, it does.
There's nothing bad with
it. I mean, there's a lot of
good aspects to coffee. It's,
it's, it's not bad for you as long
as you drink it in moderation.
But this idea that, you know, we got
fucked, we got hoodwinked. I liked the,
I liked the recipe though with,
I do a table at the pub up,
a tablespoon and a half of coconut oil,
a do a teaspoon of that butter,
that grass fed butter and a cup of coffee.
Dave's a very good collector of ideas.
He's an excellent collector of ideas,
but he's,
he doesn't have any degree in nutritional
science and in fact he got things
wrong. Completely opposite that Rhonda
Patrick was very upset about and she had a
correct on the podcast. Really? Yeah.
One of the things he got wrong was it,
but he's talking about a diet and the
effect that famine has on jeans and he got
it the total opposite way.
There have been,
there have been studies that have shown
that there's something about the body's
compensatory reaction to famine that
actually can make the children of people
who have gone through famine live longer.
He got it the opposite.
He was saying that it made the children
who had parents that had nutritional
deficits that they lived shorter lives.
It's just he doesn't understand.
He's just parroting things and that's
the problem with this whole thing with
what he's essentially done with the
bulletproof coffee thing was an idea from
the Paleo community.
Paleo community's all about healthy fats.
It's all about Avocados.
They're all about like their diet.
The term Paleo has kind of been debunked
in a sense because the Paleolithic
people, you know, they
didn't necessarily eat,
I don't like the word Paleo for that
reason because scientifically it doesn't
make sense, but here's why
it's good. The natural foods,
vegetables, meats, fishes,
those things are easy for your body
to digest. Your is very, it's normal.
You give your body a salad and a good
lean piece of chicken and your body has
100%. It knows exactly what to do
with that. There's no confusion.
You give your body a bowl
of pasta and it's like,
what the fuck is this genetically modified
grain that you've turned into a pasta
that you boiled?
And then you've got,
you've got sauce that's got
corn syrup in it, so there's,
there's fucking high fructose corn
syrup and the sauce and all this.
Your body just goes, oh cause he doesn't
know what the fuck to do with it.
That's the difference between eating
Paleo and eating processed foods that are
heavy in nitrates and antibiotics and
preservatives and all the bullshit that's
in the common, you know, modern diet.
That is where the Paleo people have it.
Right?
And that there are benefits to having
healthy fats in your diet. It's,
it's good for your skin, it's
good for your brain, you know, um,
all the,
the different essential fatty acids that
you get from fish and that you get from
different, like, like I said,
Avocados and there's a lot of benefits
to eating healthy natural foods,
so is is is the
MCT oil and the and the grass fed butter,
is that just,
is that just good fat for your
body or does that get the cause?
This is what I say,
this people that are asking,
but I don't know if this is accurate
but it helps the same way as Xanax gets
into your fat molecules.
It helps getting caffeine into your fat
mute molecule so it stays longer. Well,
this is the idea
behind it.
The idea behind it is that you blend
the butter and you blend the MCT oil and
those healthy fats combined
with the coffee and then
it gives you more of a slow
release aspect of caffeine because
your body has to absorb it slower. Now,
some people dispute that.
Alan Alan Aragon,
who I'm going to eventually get on
the podcast. Very, very bright guy.
Very interesting guy. Says
there's no proof that it, it,
it burns it slower that way, but
for me personally, I find my,
at least anecdotal evidence based on
personal experience is that when I drink
that bulletproof coffee style of coffee
called the Robb Wolf blend caught
whatever you want, it lasts longer. The,
the buzz last longer and there's no crash
because it feels like my body's slowly
digesting all the fats and it, I don't
know, it just works. I know I don't,
but I'm not a scientist.
I'm not a doctor.
I don't think it's a placebo effect
because when I drink black coffee,
which we do all the time here as well,
sometimes Jamie,
we'll just make the black coffee.
I feel like I crash.
It goes up and it goes down and I think
it just gets in your bloodstream quicker,
isn't it? It's not attached to fats. I
love it. I love the buttery on my top lip.
When you can get like it tastes
good, tastes fucking good. I like it.
For breakfast, I w I mean, look, I made
sure that I get a lot of nutrients.
I make sure I get a lot of
healthy leafy green vegetables.
I eat a lot of spinach and
Kale and Broccoli and all
kinds of, I think it's very,
that's one of the most important things
to get is get healthy plant based
nutrients.
I think it's one of the things that's
missing from a lot of people's diets.
You don't give it a fresh vegetables,
but you know, sometimes I'll,
I won't eat until like, you know, two or
three in the afternoon and the whole day.
All haven't you haven't
eaten since noon today? Yeah,
I haven't had bulletproof coffee and um,
I had a protein I worked out too.
I worked out and then,
uh, maybe two minutes.
I think the, I did battle
ropes. Oh, did you really?
Like you're riding an elephant.
Yeah.
Is Con bomb Alexander the Great,
speaking of getting his con,
I watched the 300,
the new 300 John Wayne played
Gingiss calm the movie. Oh yes,
I did played it.
We played it on the podcast before.
Big [inaudible] dog shit. So
sorry to interrupt. No, it's okay.
It's so bad. It's worth
talking about. It's amazing.
Maybe we could pull it up again.
Pull it up again John.
Wayne is Gaviscon cause it's so fucking
stupid. There are a lot of Asians around.
How that new thing a hundred
though. Terrible. Oh really?
It's a hunk of shit. Ooh.
How about snow piercer what's that?
I've heard it's one that Jamie
was telling me about. Yeah, no
I haven't seen it.
They they they,
it is the first product that is now
proving the video on demand is going to be
better than movie theaters because,
I mean think about how pimp you've
making your place to watch movies.
I mean mine is, I, I fucking lock
down my man cave surround sound.
I got post screens going so I can go
like this and it's Kinda like, uh, like,
you know, I feel like I'm
getting sucker punched picture.
You was like a two by four that you slap
under. Don't like one of those fucking,
you know how they lock up like a castle
door along with a big fucking bolt.
Oh, I love it. I put my Aye.
Aye. Aye. Aye. It's my favorite.
You should have a red light that goes
off when your wife needs to get ahold of
you in the, we should get ahold of you.
We have walkie talkies and they call me.
They call me papa bear. Goldilocks.
Papa bear. Goldilocks. Rapala. No,
you're such a maniac on my donor.
My daughter's talking on walkie talkie.
Lango copy that. Uh, that's so funny.
Go for it. Go for Goldie locks.
So ridiculous about that Lucy movie. That
looks awesome. It looks like dog shit.
Yeah, it's the same thing over
and over again. How many movies
take where someone takes something and
they become superhuman? You know? Oh,
it's fucking limitless. It's
Lucy. It's this. It's that.
You know what's going to happen?
She's going to win and then it'll
probably like wear off at the end and she
become a normal chick and
she'll get knocked up and
live in the suburbs and then
the CIA will drive by her house real
slow just to make sure that she's not
fucking flipping cars through
the air with a brand anymore.
But she'll be writing a blog.
Yeah.
You remember how like the
Bradley Cooper movie limitless.
Fascinating to the end. They wrapped
it up with a fucking bow of shit.
It's like the way they ended it with
so dumb that he like figured out how to
fucking fix it all on his own so
it doesn't like how, how did he,
how did he solve the one major problem
with this stuff that it wore off and
fucked you up after it was over?
Are you ready for the greatest movie
ever? Okay. Uh, with your kids.
Have you seen the Lego movie? Yes.
Amazing. The greatest fucking movie.
Everything is awesome.
Move for adults. Kids
enjoying. Yeah. Let's see.
Gaviscon John Wayne is tag. Oh, they
made a preview of the recut version.
They tried to make it cooler
and civilization. Ancestors, that's fine.
Dying be without bloodshed.
The cal bad. The set looks,
my spirit may forever counseling,
protect the crates,
all fat and shit.
Hot. Listen to me. There are
moments where wisdom Jim Oga,
then I listened to you.
I'm Oka and are moments for action.
Then I listened to my blood.
I feel less tired or a
woman is from a backhander.
I've taken you over white board ty and
I take your dowry tomorrow and our Gut,
I make gift of it. Dwayne
con. Oh my God, please.
My strength in CG of Wang Con city.
Hi
[inaudible].
First of all,
how bad an actor was John Wayne,
apparently all you had to be as
white back then. Yeah, that's it.
It's fucking terrible.
I mean he did remotely sound
Mongolian Talk Mongolia.
But isn't it also weird that that was
like essentially like you talking about
like was it probably like the
sixties right? They made that
closer to the gang con days than today,
right?
It's 2014 obviously that was closer.
I mean not a lot closer but close
enough where it's measurable. Yeah,
but so far off of what the
Mongols were really like.
Whereas today you could never
make that movie like that.
Could you imagine like let's say if Ryan
Gosling wanted to play kingus Khan and
he was just fucking sleepwalking through
it, just like that John went click,
you'd be like,
what a fucking piece of shit is this?
But for whatever reason
where people dumber, then
definitely and no one, no one had
any reference for who Genghis Khan,
but how would they dumb or then if they
had already invented the atomic bomb,
we couldn't invent the atomic pop.
So someone in the 1940s Oppenheimer was
way fucking smarter than anyone in this
room. I'm sure Oppenheimer did not want
to see that movie. I'm sure it was like,
wait, you have to do is Asian. Right?
But like think about how many geniuses
they're work Teslow was the beginning of
the 20th century. You know
that you're, you're talking
about super, super geniuses,
incredibly brilliant people,
but yet the general population would
accept a hunk of shit like that.
I mean that is a really bad movie.
This is a theory that Duncan
I got into and I had the,
I had an idea and I asked Duncan
about it and Duncan took his,
I took the idea to the next level,
but the idea was I was trying
to Google what Christ's Iq was.
Let's see if what he got on the
Iq test and it's zero it within,
never had accused back then
knowing I never didn't exist.
How about Jesus Christ?
So,
but that was like,
I wonder if like Jesus was smarter than
the average person are dumber than the
average person.
And Duncan brought about premise he had
were that everyone was basically like a
mentally challenged except for
Jesus who was the first person.
So it was like something about Mary,
like you had basically visit the baseball
behind your ear and they're like,
here's Morgan beans. But, uh, I
think that was Dunkin's theory.
I'm fucking ruin conversations
I have with people.
Don't get hard on yourself too. You
always do these seven guys right there,
but you were doing great. But, uh,
but I think that, I think that,
I would guess that based on the internet
or the information that we have,
our level of basic intelligence has
increased exponentially from 1960.
Well,
I don't know if our intelligence has,
but our knowledge has, that's
right. Yeah. I mean the, the, the,
the capacity to hold information
seems to be the same.
That's why we run into issues like there's
an issue with that. You know, the, um,
the, the Dunbar number, like 150 people,
they keep 150 people in your,
in your mind, that's what you,
your memories capable of holding in
their hundred 50 people that you have
intimate relationships with,
that you're friends with.
Anything more than 150
shit gets really weird.
You run out of hard
drive space and it's a,
this is a scientific number and it's based
on the capacity to recognize how many
people are in a tribe and they average
tribe. When human beings were, you know,
coming up was like 50 to a hundred,
150 people maximum.
That's all he needed to have.
Now,
especially if you're a guy like Bert
Kreischer traveling all over the world
doing stand up comedy, how many fucking
people have you met? God dammit, Dude,
you've met thousands and
thousands of people and if
you might run into some dude,
you might do a show in Australia and
you run into that dude and he like, Hey,
remember we talked last year?
And you're like, no, I've,
does that freak you out when
someone says, Oh yeah, we hung out.
Like we worked on a TV show together for
a year and you're like flat line, like,
you know what really freaks me out when
I can't remember it. I can't remember.
I can't remember. I can't remember
it at all. And then, oh yeah.
And then it starts appearing in my
memory and then I'm like, where was that?
Where was that? I'm just pulling
it out now and like, God,
I totally forgot about that.
I've met people again like after having
met them before and then all of a sudden
the whole evening where I met them like,
Oh yeah,
we were talking to Doug and he told
you that thing. Oh yeah. Oh yeah.
But before they like a stranger,
there were a total stranger until
whatever it was started reappearing in the
back of my retrieving your
data back from the cloud. Yeah,
I don't get it then that's
the next Lucy movie.
What if they didn't make her smarter?
They just increased her hard drive
so she can remember everyone.
That's why she prayed them.
The basis of the movie as she's using
more of her brain said like the chemical
let you open.
That's one of the reasons why that movie
is going to suck because that premise
has already been disproven by science.
It's not that you only use a certain
percentage of your brain. That's not true.
Like this idea of humans only use 10%
of their brain. They said that in the,
in the preview. I was
like, no, they don't. They,
they're just starting to understand what
parts of the brain are responsible for
what functions. And one of the
things that they're doing this,
this is really interesting shit.
I think it's called transcranial TTC,
d something or another.
They're putting electrical stimulation
on various aspects or various, uh,
points of, of this, of your skull.
They're putting electrodes on your skull
and they're inducing like this state by
emitting electricity and it feels
like mosquitoes are biting you.
There's a great,
um,
episode of this podcast I
listened to all the time.
Radio lab, a recent one. I think the
most recent one in fact is about this.
And this woman went through
this, uh, this, they're,
they're learning that it can increase
your capacity to learn, like dramatically,
dramatically and provable.
So this woman went through
this thing where she went
through sniper training. So,
uh, in this sniper training scenario,
they a first you'd do it sober. They,
they take you through this
thing. There's a, you're at a,
a checkpoint like in Iraq, you
know, it's all video simulation.
A bomb blows up and the suicide bombers
are running at you with bomb vests on
and they're shooting guns at you and
you gotta figure out who's who and pick
them off. Well, the first time she
did it, it was super frustrating.
She got like three out of 20, and she
just kept and kept getting fucked up.
It was driving her crazy.
He was driving her nuts.
Then they put the electrodes on,
they juiced to brain,
they put electrodes on her brain and her,
uh, the, the side of her head and on her,
uh, left arm somehow or
another, like her right brain,
the right side of her head and her
left arm. And then she was like,
this isn't going to do anything.
She didn't feel any different. She,
she said she felt like a
metallic taste in their mouth,
like she had just licked an
aluminum can or something like that.
Then went through the thing and she
said everything moved in slow motion.
She said 20 minutes went by in
three minutes. When it was over,
she couldn't believe it was over. She's
like, how was it over? She's like, it's,
it's only been three minutes. And
they like, no, look at the clock.
She looked at the clock.
20 minutes has gone by.
She was a hundred percent accurate,
so from three out of 20 she got 20 out
of 20 the second time and she thought it
only took three minutes.
She just went through this thing like
she was an expert and they were like,
she became like an assassin. Yeah. Yeah.
Ohio state actually just had a guy
that was paralyzed and they've been,
they found how to control the brain for
him to actually a move for your first
time or something like that. Yeah.
That's different. Yeah. I mean,
we're talking different, we're talking
that's, that's still fascinating.
But this is through the average person.
This is not people that are paralyzed.
The average person,
they can increase your capacity to learn
by using this transdermal stimulation.
Transcranial direct stimulation,
I think it's called.
I got, I got a serious injury
head injury I had in college.
I got knocked unconscious.
What happened?
You've got to fight and a dude kind
of fucked me up. I wrote a song,
a comic song and he
didn't find it very funny.
So I beat you up and knocked her
unconscious. My good friend too.
He was my really good friend. Yeah, he was
older than I was. He was, uh, he was old.
He was like two years old, three years
older than I was. What was it about,
what was the song about?
About our fraternity? I sang
a song about a fraternity,
like lighthearted song making fun of all
the brothers and that were older than
me obviously, and he didn't find it
funny and so, but I was as friends,
so I was like, we're not going to
fight. But then I was, I was wrong
and he grabbed me and like suplex
to me and, and like, like you know,
like the, like you would like if you're
going to throw someone like full,
you know what I mean? Like over
your shoulder backwards, let him,
I let him on my head and I was,
I was out and then I came to,
I was really confused and then I came to,
and he was on of me
trying to say, cause I think I would
swallow my tongue or something.
I'm not certain. But then
I, but then I got lost.
I walked around campus and I got lost
and I was really confused as let you go.
I was in maternity, it was, it was
a fight and then I just walked away.
Like I just walked away. It was
during exams and so I just walked out.
So your fraternity brothers didn't take
you to a fucking doctor who's there?
You got knocked unconscious. He
was the only one there. It was,
he didn't take you to a doctor?
No. No. Well he just beat me up.
I don't think he was concerned about
my wellbeing fraternity in Florida.
Did you stay friends with this guy? No.
You should've called the cops. Uh, yeah.
Well, yeah, there was a lot. I mean it,
long story short fucking asshole. Yeah.
So, um, he uh, so I, I went to the
hospital and I had some headaches.
I had like minor amnesia,
like meaning I had a hard
time remembering some shit.
They asked me where I went to school and
I was like, Jesuit was my first answer.
That was my high school and my roommate
at the time was there and he was like,
oh fuck. And so then, uh,
I did a bunch of testing
and the doctors were like,
I think everything's going to be fine.
I think it'd be fine.
I think you just got your Bell Rung and
uh, Ms Back when they used the fifties,
when, when was this
going on? This is 1992.
Did they not understand how fucking
dangerous concussions are? Not at all.
That jazz me crazy man.
People that have a lack of understanding
about head injuries try it drives me
fucking nuts. He could go to a doctor.
There wasn't, it was Tallahassee, Florida,
probably hoping you're dying to get
rid of him. So many fucking my mind.
My Dad's really, uh, really nervous kind
of guy. And so when I went to Tampa,
I got like the thing where they put
you in the thing and the cat scan or
whatever.
And then they did this thing where they
put electrodes all over my head to all
over my head.
And then they put this light in
front of my face and it flashed like,
it was like the rainbow color, but it was
just, it was just going like different,
like pulses and like different things.
And you had just sit there
with your eyes closed,
but you could see it clear as
fuck with your eyes closed.
And then they did a test in your brain.
They did reading comprehension and they're
like, I think are going to be fine.
He just had to, you know, you got a
concussion and you were out. You'll,
you'll come back. That guy's a piece of
shit, man. Yeah. Suplex you and your head.
You know that that is so fucking dangerous
to do that to someone on the street.
It's so dangerous. That's the number
one way to people die in street fights.
You know, they fall and hit
their head on the street. Yeah.
There's a guy in college that punched
the guy and knocked him unconscious and
the guy landed on a, uh, on a, on a
parking curb, a parking thing, and,
and died. That happened to a guy
that Kevin James used to work with.
Kevin James was a bouncer.
He worked with this other bouncer and
the bouncer punched the guy in the head.
The guy got knocked unconscious, fell
back, hit his head on a curb, dad, fuck,
it's a course.
I mean,
think about what it would be like if
you hit someone in the head with a curb
stone. Yeah. You know, going 30 miles an
hour, just smash him in the head. Well,
that's what it's like when you fall
backwards and you hit the curb and you're,
you're,
you're basically getting your fucking
brain bashed in with all your body weight.
It's super dangerous.
So this dickhead
fucking whatever. I'm sorry. Yeah, it's
okay. So, so what happened from then on?
No, nothing. I, I recovered.
They were like, don't, uh,
the doctor was like, Shit,
you stay away from booze and any like
pod or anything in that last couple of
hours. Not even, I think that first
night I got drunk, I was like, I think
I'm way more drones,
like just fucking candle concussions rule.
But uh, but yeah, it was, I was fine. I'm,
yeah, that was fine. This, um,
episode of Radio Lab, if Ben,
nobody wants to listen to,
it's called nine volt Nirvana.
And if you've never heard radio,
radio lab before is my favorite
podcast right now. I really enjoy it.
It's really good. It's so, so well
made. And they, each one of them,
it takes a long time to make once they
only put one out like every few weeks or
so. But it's really good
stuff. Really good stuff.
But it's all about this transcranial,
it's called transcranial
electrical stimulation. And, um,
if you just look up transcranial
direct current stimulation,
um, there are many, many articles
about it online and many,
many different studies that have been
done. Really fucking fascinating stuff.
But if you're learning something,
apparently there's a bunch of dudes have
done like do it yourself versions of it
too with a,
you can apparently you could build your
own transcranial electrical stimulation
device. Uh, uh, with some shit
that you buy from radio shack.
I'm fucking really make myself gay or oh,
you mean get it right.
It's like Ghostbusters at the beginning
when he has all those things on his head.
There was a video
or,
or there was an article might be bullshit,
but a guy was a rugby player who got
knocked out and he got a concussion and
turn gay.
I don't believe that
we've talked about that.
Remember this pit, the before
pictures. He's like, Hi guys,
I'm playing rugby.
He looked totally straight.
Totally straight. Looks like cause
whatever it is, rock Hudson looked like it
did. I bet. I bet so many dudes
were tricked into sucking his dick.
He has the king of the among goals.
Tell you now rock.
Yeah. How many dudes were tricked in?
Well, that's the Travolta move, right?
Isn't that the idea? I've heard stories
about guys we know. Nevermind. Hey,
keep going. Why stop now? What
are you saying? I've heard it.
I've heard stories of like of like famous
people that Scientologists maybe no,
but famous people who have gotten dudes
that are like young comics to suck their
dicks. Oh yeah. And then they're like, I
don't know what happened. I was telling.
Sure. Yeah, that's totally true. Yeah.
This is something that's straight
guys get a kick out of doing that or,
or gay guys rather get a kick out of
getting straight guys to suck their dick.
I was a friend that
I'm used to work at. Um, uh, he was on um,
a fear factor and a couple of shows
that I did. He was a good guy.
He was a wardrobe guy and he was do's
long gang to get big Mexican gay guy.
Awesome dude. Um, but anyway,
he would tell me all the time that like,
like guys would get drunk,
like straight guys who get drunk and wind
up blowing them. And I was like, really?
He goes, yeah, we're having me blow
them. I was like, really? And he goes to,
they would always say, I've never done
this before. I go, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Like I don't, you know,
then, then the question is
where they really straight all
along or were they, you know,
were they just the alcohol
brought out the gain? Um,
they were really gay and they
just didn't want to admit it.
That's, I have a joke about
that, that I'm not homophobic.
I'm a Homo Kondracke like I'm comfortable
if your game's free one night you'll
get me drunk and trick me into it
and I'll like it. I'll be like, aw,
this is my jam. Tom Ziglar and I
went out with a gay dude one night.
Our trainer was gay and he was like,
why don't you guys come out with us?
And Tom and I were like, like, and he's
like, well, go to gay clubs. Tom was like,
you want to go? I was like, fuck yeah.
Why don't you guys come out with us?
We're going to go to gay clubs and Tom
and I went and like Tom dressed like
youth spruced up.
Did he really collared shirt
on. I'm like Tom. And he's like,
what were ms can be jeans.
I'm wearing skinny jeans and a collared
shirt and shoes. It was fucking his wolf.
Shoot.
Whatever those big bear paws fit into.
But Tonya has so much fucking fun.
We Sat,
we sat together drinking like the gay
strengths that tastes awesome by the way.
What's the gain strength like a
like cosmos and Pina coladas. Nope.
Delicious am Tom and I were
like, no beers. We're not,
we don't have to do shots and left.
It's like a like a sex on the beach.
We had the best fucking time.
Well you remember Scott Kennedy and he's
like the street straight as gay guy of
all time. Yeah. Yeah. He's gay as fuck.
But you would think he's like the
straight beer drink in football fan.
I always had a football Jersey
on. He died, died a few years ago.
I don't remember what,
I think he died in his sleep and then he
has sleep apnea or something like that.
He's a big guy. His stroke, I think
Justin Martin Dale Party. What's that?
I didn't know Justin Martin. Dale is gay
for like the first six months. I knew.
How is that even possible? I
never saw him drunk. I think he,
when he's not, when he's sober,
he, how much does watch them walk?
Guess Scott is fuck Scott Kennedy that
Scott Kennedy and I
were drinking one night.
I kind of wish I could remember
how this story exactly went,
but we were sitting drinking
in Sacramento and uh,
and I saw this dude walked by. That was
just a mess. I was like, God. And I'm,
but I wasn't thinking. I was
like, can you imagine being him?
Like having to have his life and I,
it's calculus that doesn't turn you on.
And I go turn me on. And Scott goes, one
man's trash is another man's treasure.
One man's trash is we're
fubu jerseys or foot football
jerseys. Well, one of
the other, yeah. Yeah,
I gaydar doesn't really work
well with comedians though.
Cause if he'd hang out
at the comedy store,
you would say half the people were gay.
But they're not supposedly, you know,
there's just the large groups of people
that cause their comics and they all
know each other.
They all of act gay or the
normal. What are you talking about?
I never explained so Benji's gay,
you know Benji, I would think Benji's gay,
but he's not. And Tony, perfect example.
I would think Tony's gay, but
he's not. You would think,
oh Tony Asher, who was gay.
Why? Just cause he's small. I mean I guess
you could hold them down and fucking,
no, no, no. I think it's just like little
things. That's how he carries himself.
You know, like a lot of people like
he's like, he has a joke about it.
He has a gay face, you know
it. Well he's very small,
but I wouldn't think he was gay. I
don't know. He's just against maybe,
well how he dresses.
He's personally to be cardigan thing.
It's a very funny thing.
The cardigan thing,
like are you remember
the Ari's Cardigan phase?
He was giving me a hard time about
fanny packs. I'm like, bitch,
I never said a word during
your cardigan phase.
What about Ari's like Bozo the clown
phase where he just shaved like hit like a
bald spot but left the hair around the
side of his head. Do that one day though.
Oh, it was that one day. I
thought it was a while. No,
I remember he grew a Hitler
mustache. Yeah, that was
weird. He shaved. He's Jewish,
I think if anybody's allowed to
rock a Hitler mustache. Oh yeah.
Remember when he had to wear his hat on
the side of his head during that time we
had like a Hitler mustache and then he
had a small house, like a beanie beanie.
He wore sideways.
Yeah.
He's being silly or is that an
interesting fucking guy? Okay,
a real kick out of that guy.
He was the first one that
proved he h he in a weird way,
kind of changed the way I hang out with
people and me and him talked about this.
A lot of people have heard me say this,
but [inaudible] was the
first person that I saw.
I saw the amazing racist and I really
liked it and I went up to him at a comedy
club and I was like in Tripoli did the
same thing to me. And I said, hey man,
I saw your amazing racist. I really
liked it. I think you're really funny.
And it was like the, the tension between
two comics who didn't know each other,
just was no longer there.
And then we became friends and it was
like all you have to do is really just be
nice to people and people
are nice right back.
What do you mean? Like, is
that confusing? Yeah. Like,
well I know how to find water.
You Rub a stick on a rock
and it makes it water.
No, but like sometimes with
comics it's like there is this,
like if you don't know a comic then
you're like kind of Kentucky about it.
And so like you're,
yeah,
there's a lot of comedy and like think
of like the different scenes that go on
and everyone was like, ah, yeah.
Like just a, that kind of shit.
But I saw Ari and Sam Aaa did the
same thing. He came to me one night.
He was like, I really like that
joke years. I was like, oh my God,
we're friends now. I like you.
You like me. I like me. Yeah, some
comics definitely. I'm a standoffish
thing about other comics,
but you know Tony Hinchcliffe and I
were talking about that the difference
between the nineties when I started out
at the comedy store in [inaudible] 94
there was no comradery there.
It was, it was all for,
it was like this weird,
everybody was out for themselves.
There wasn't like a lot
of pal around together.
It wasn't that same
sort of an environment.
I mean it was a lot of good comics and
people would go up and they would do sets
and stuff like that. And you
know, it was always kind of a,
an interesting place to perform,
but it was,
there was no like comradery amongst
comedians like there is now,
especially like our group, that's a very,
this is a very unusual group. All of us,
like Diaz and Ari and Dunkin and
everyone together be in pals and Cowan.
And that shit just didn't exist.
We w I had never known like a group
that was like that tightly knit,
that work together all the time to
constantly went on the road together and
brought each other around
and then support each other.
And then the podcast thing came along
and everybody started doing each other's
podcasts and supporting each other and
having each other on their podcast to
promote things. And that just doesn't, it
didn't exist before. It wasn't like that.
There was people, comics were way more
standoffish. It was way less of a,
a pal around thing.
And one of the things that I think
that I attributed to changing it, um,
it changed a little bit in New York.
First tough crowd changed it.
It kind of started to see that these
guys were buddies and they're palling
around together and then they
started doing ona together, like Ona,
change it a lot.
And then guys were hanging around at
the cellar a lot and it became like,
there was more comradery,
you know,
he started to see that that more
calmer ona made a big impact.
They made a big impact because everybody
that went on ona became kind of pals,
you know?
I mean there's always little disputes
here and there between guys that would go
on it. But it was like opie and Anthony
became like a place where everybody,
you know, everybody who did it, you were
like a part of, I was like a club. Yeah,
it's, I was, uh, I've,
I've told this to Jim,
but I've a been a huge
ona fan for a long time.
And those moments when like, like the
other night, the other day when they were,
had Pete rose on and did you hear
the one with rich Vos and Pete rose?
Rich Vos was on fucking
fire. Yeah, he was,
he was on fire and I
could not stop laughing.
And you think and like I know all those
guys from starting in New York, I and I,
it is identical to how they'd hang out
with each other the best I've ever,
one of my favorite moments
in standup was when, uh,
Patrice used to heckle Voss so they'd
go to the Boston comedy club and fosters
get on stage and it was
almost like watching,
it was almost like watching
Eddie and Hixon, you know,
like, like they were wrote,
they'd roll together and put,
but Patrice would heckle him now,
no one knew Patrice was a comic.
He was just a big black guy in the back
and foster get on stage and he's like,
man,
Yo teeth looked like tombstones and
boss would come out and they go back and
forth and it was so much fun and I was
like, this has got to do something.
They're going to be something they're
going to do later. But it was like,
it was amazing and foss was so fucking
quick buy used to sit in the back and
just watch it.
Like watching two masters go at it.
Yeah, Vasa very quick. And that led to
all those guys became friends from opiate.
Anthony that,
yeah,
I don't know that the camaraderie between
Comedians is so important is it's huge
because comedians on their own like,
like I dunno this is this something that
nomadic sort of thing that comics do.
Traveling the road being
on your own all the time.
The guys who like really
depressed and sad,
they'd be like never would pal around
with other comedians. They would like,
they would never go on the road with
other comedians or they would take some on
the road that they didn't know.
Just like that was just a job like you
open for me and we're not really friends.
Yeah. That, that I, that always seem to
me to be the worst way to to it. You know,
it's fun to be going through some shit
and call one of you guys and just be like,
oh fuck this is this. This is
how I'm feeling. Like Joey,
he's Joey's might go to phone call always.
If I'm depressed I'll call Joey.
Cause it's, you know, it's,
the conversation can be no longer than
three minutes and it's going to end with
that going to be fine. Cock sucker.
Yeah. Well I've coffee next week.
Well it's like perfect example,
secure segora had a terrible
show thinking Winnipeg and he uh,
yeah,
he came on the podcast and talked about
it and because we know we're all comics
together, you know, we're laughing
and having fun just, you know,
completely got through this terrible
tragic memory and it became hilarious.
It became like fun.
I love when he bombs
so rare.
He's really fucking funny.
It's like when it's like when you
shoot a bear with a bow and Arrow,
but they don't know
they've been injured yet,
but they know that if you shot with a bow
and Arrow, I watched a lot of hunting.
I watched a lot of hunting videos
like I used to, I used to, if I,
if I ever got too fucked up within,
I'd watch hunting in Florida,
it's very easy to get really bear
bear hunting from, in my opinion,
you've done it. I've never done
it. But all the videos are,
they like put a box out full of food and
then they'd sit in a tent and then the
bear would come out and they shoot it
with a bow and Arrow and the bear would
get hit, but it would almost feel, it
would seem like the bear be like, oh,
what the fuck was that?
And then you'd see the look in the
bear's face where they'd be like,
I don't feel good.
I'm going to go rest for a little bit.
That's how sick girl looks. When he bombs.
It's like, it's like, he's like, he like,
he looks at you like, did I get, did I
get hit? And you're like, and you're,
and you know, he's been hit by an arrow.
My favorite one was in, uh, in, in, uh,
in Pearl Harbor. Me, Pearl Harbor,
Hawaii, me, Thompson, Hoorah.
And Russell Peters. And,
uh, I go up and I do okay,
but maybe I was dirtier
than I should have been,
but it's totally fine because
the only real thing that we're,
don't make fun of the Hawaiians, that
was it. Don't make fun of the Hawaiians.
And don't bring up Pearl Harbor.
What? Tom's opening joke. He's like,
man, it's a lot of fat people. He's like,
I heard island life was slow slope.
I know they were talking
about their metabolism,
so then he says I got lost walking around.
Luckily a Japanese guy pointed out the
directions man, those Japanese, no,
this place like the back of their hand.
I mean he bombed so hard that when he got
off he was like that early sweats like
where you could and he's like, he's
like, oh, pretty good and you're like,
you might want to go back
to your nest and rock.
You know Tom's going to lose his shit.
That video of where I'm shaving Tom.
That's that week?
Yeah.
How many more after the show before
how many shows did you guys do? One.
Just one and pro. Just one. I went up, I
was a little dirty. I think Tom went up,
had a rough set. He, he
kind of went back, you know,
Tom is not right for corporate gig in
that opinion and there's a corporate gig.
It was the,
for the,
it was like maybe I want to say
3000 people on at Pearl Harbor,
sitting in lawn chairs with their
families. What was the Gig like? What,
who is it for? For the Pearl.
For the USO. Ah, that's fine.
That's a military gear, not
corporate kid. That same same energy.
So I, and so then Tom sits next
to me, this is my favorite part.
Thompson texted me and Russell Peters
comes on stage and you can hear there's a
murmuring now mind you,
we're at war with Iraq and Russell
Peters is a little brown for their taste.
And Tom Goes,
I never realized he looks like the enemy.
And Russell Peters is by the way,
didn't acknowledge it did had a great set,
but you could hear that kind of like they
brought up one of the like and Tom and
I were in the back like this is bad.
We the next day.
And you thought it was
bad because he was brown.
It was only because we had gone to rifle
training the day before and Russell had
randomly chose not to go randomly. And
the first words that rifle training was,
there's one rule here. If it's
brown and it moves, you kill it.
And Tom was like, he didn't
bring ruffle. Let the fuck.
Imagine if you're Mexican and you're in
the fucking army and they tell you that
shit. If it's brown and it moves, we
kill it. Whoa. That guy said that.
And we brought our wives to it.
We, we've had arrives to rifle.
We shot every gun they had. We brought
our wives and the girls were like,
right before we went, stepped in, they go,
can we go to the bathroom? Or like, yeah,
go to the bathroom. So we walk
in and the guy's like, uh,
I thought they were going to be six.
He's like a real military guy.
And we're like, yeah, the girls
went to the bathroom. He was okay.
And then Tom goes, hey, do
me a favor. When they get in,
act a little like aggressive to them
and misogynistic and let's just see the
looks on their faces. So the
girls walk in and he was on, well,
typical lady's got lost.
Don't know what time it is of
their man's not next to him.
And Christina and my wife started
bubbling like what the, and he's like,
ladies do follow the men. They'll
know what to do. Thank you gentlemen.
And he got into character so good that
Tom stepped in. He's like, it's a joke.
Everybody hits a joke.
He's doing it because we asked him to.
This guy was good. Wow.
That's funny. Yeah.
That's hilarious.
Yeah.
It's funny that you can get
a trained killer to just
crack jokes. Oh, the guy was,
it was, that was a really
fun trip. If it's Brown, kill
it. If it's Brown, it moves.
You kill it. Do you enjoy that?
You have to Osha this junk.
Have you ever done those? Nope.
No, I don't enjoy them now. I mean,
I do them, I do them, but I would just,
I'd be doing it to bomb because you can't
really be dirty. He can't really curse.
There's a bunch of rules
you can't talk about.
And I'd probably break
all of them and the,
those corporate things I've
learned I'm just not good at.
Yeah.
And there's also the thing of like,
you got to go to military bases and just
the whole thing about it is I am 100%
in support of the actual people.
But the idea behind it is this,
I'm not going to Afghanistan. I'm not,
I'm not going to Iraq and telling jokes,
you know,
I just like,
I get that they need a break and
they need a entertainment and I get,
it's a great service, but
all that, that's just that,
that is not a place I want to go. I think
everything about it is fucking like,
imagine going to Gaza right
now. Cracking jokes, magic.
If you had a fucking
Uso tour gig and Gaza,
like what is going on with Gaza without
fuck is going on with Israel and
Palestine. What started all of this?
If you paid attention to this, uh,
very subtly, dude, I'm trying not
to, but I have to. I mean everybody,
I get all these tweets, you're not coming
and going. He goes, well look man, when I,
when I see about death and destruction,
I don't gravitate towards it.
I don't like try to study it.
And try to figure out exactly what's
going on so I could pick a side and have a
viewpoint. I just get sad that there's
more of this bullshit in the world.
I don't, I don't like feel like I'm going
to fix it with my opinion and I don't,
I don't, I keep hearing all
these people have these ideas.
One side will say it's
definitely Israel's fault.
One side will say Hamas is like,
uh,
like Bill Maher said something about
Hamas is like a crazy ex girlfriend.
You know,
like a crazy girl.
Like she should eventually have to
smack her or something like that.
Like I don't,
what the fuck he said it was some,
some weird like hacky thing that he was
saying in regards to a war that's going
on between this really troubled part
of the world. And you know, the,
my number one thing about war,
the number one thing is on an
individual basis, regardless of,
you know, take out the context
of the civilization they live in,
the culture they live in, the,
the, the language that they speak.
These people don't know each other.
Why are they fighting to the death?
They don't even know each other there.
You're launching missiles
at people you've never met.
They're shooting back at you.
It's crazy.
The fact that we still do it in 2014 I
don't give a fuck who side you should be
on or what it represents. It represents
the fact that we're still retarded.
It represents the fact that we still
can't figure out how to overcome our
differences with any other way other
than shooting missiles at each other or
dropping bombs or setting up IED or
shooting people at checkpoints or whatever
it is,
whatever method that they choose to
to show that we're still in some way
barbarians and that's what it is.
We're barbarians with way better weapons.
It's fucking crazy.
I understand that sometimes there's acts
of aggression and you need to protect
people from people more barbaric than us,
but it makes me sad.
I mean,
that's the only other way.
The only way I know to
describe my feelings about
anything that happens with war
in the news.
Anytime violence breaks out any anytime,
like this Gaza,
Palestine thing,
I just get just depressed at my core.
I can't read about it. I'm not
going to pick a side. I'm not,
my side is the human side.
On my Mama.
I'm on the human race side and the
human race is not benefiting from this
fucking shit.
I don't know what it would take to cause
Palestine and Israel to be cool with
each other. I don't
understand it. I don't,
I don't know how you could
hate each other for so long.
How you could have so many
different points of view.
How you get a guy like Dennis Prager who
says Palestine will not be happy unless
Israel is dead. There is no negotiating.
I'll come. They're fucking people.
They're people.
I don't know how they're communicating.
I don't know if they understand
each other's language.
I don't know how much of this is just
deep seated ancient shit that these people
have just carried with them forever.
But my position on it,
I'm not taking any sides.
My position on it is the whole
thing is completely fucked.
The whole thing fucked.
It's fucked that people still do this.
It's fucked until we recognize it. It's
fucked. And maybe if I lived in Israel,
I'd have a totally
different state of mind.
Maybe if I lived in a place that was
regularly attacked and at war I would be
more harsh and more closed off to it. I
don't know. I don't know. But you know,
for people who want my take on it to keep
tweeting me about it, that's my take.
My take is it's, I'm tired
of living my life. I mean,
look, I'm 46, I'll be 47 in
August. At what point in time? Um,
I mean as a,
as a person,
I've grown and matured and I understand
myself and how I interface with other
people and society and culture
much better. I'm much better at it.
But when I look at like
human beings in general,
I don't necessarily know if I see
that much growth when it comes to
international relations,
when it comes to war,
when it comes to the way we
react to each other, I just,
I keep seeing the same fucking patterns
repeating themselves over and over again.
Whether it's in Iraq,
whether it's in this idea that
we're supposed to invade Syria,
where you get fucking Dick Cheney who
goes in the news the other day and they
did an interview with him.
He said his number one regret that he
didn't invade Iran at the same time they
invaded Iraq. You know, I just,
I'm disappointed in, in human beings, I
think there's gonna come a certain time,
but we have to get to
the root of the problem.
Why did these things always have
to end in unfathomable violence?
Like what is it about human beings
and is it the way we're being led?
Is the way we're being governed
or is it something about us?
Some fundamental aspect of
what we are as a, as a being.
I don't have the answer to that,
but I know that me as a person who hopes
for the best wishes for the best in in
human beings, I see this and it just makes
me sad, is no other way to describe it.
I know that's a very limited way
of describing things and it's,
it leaves a lot open to interpretation.
That's how I feel about it. I just,
I look at the news every day. I mean,
look, we can go to CNN right now.
I'll go to cnn.com and I guarantee you
it's fucking death and destruction this
weekend. Uh, 47 people shot five
dead and just Chicago. Well,
Chicago was going through some serious
fucking gang violence. Really? Yeah, sure.
It's gang violence. And uh, I was
talking to a guy last time was there,
it was a former cop and his take on it
was that what happened was there was some
major players in the drug game that were
arrested and they left a vacuum because
there's these gang members
that got arrested and there
was a power vacuum that's
being filled now with violence.
So yeah,
it's probably more people dead
right in there then it isn't Gaza.
More people been killed by
cops than died in the Iraq war.
So funny if you said to me though,
would you rather go to Gaza or Chicago?
I'd be like, oh, Chicago.
Yeah. Well most of Chicago safe as
fuck. It's the south side of Chicago.
You go to the ghetto.
That's where you might as well be in Gaza.
I used to do a great club down there,
riddles in the south side of Chicago.
Hello blog. When did you do
the south side of Chicago? But
when I first started, the guy named Brent,
I was just talking to them about it.
So a guy named Brent used to run it.
You get two grand for the weekend.
Oh you had to do was Friday and Saturday,
two shows each night.
It was really nice and
it was an all backup,
all black tee shirt off and fucking
saying no fucking [inaudible] songs.
I would do it,
I could have whatever I would,
I remember my first joke,
the first time I worked there was
about Duran Duran and some black ticks.
Like who the fuck's he? I was like, it's
a band. And she's like, oh no, no Brent,
you better talk about black people,
mother fucker. And I was like done.
So I spent the rest of the week just to
an all black jokes and I fucking loved
it. I had, so I guess it was like
getting away with everything.
And I remember like a dude stood up and
proposed to his chick in the middle of
one of my shows. I was like, fuck
yeah, I was chaos. It is pretty crazy.
At 47 people shots in Chicago.
Yeah.
It's weird how it like most cities it's
always like the south side is the bad
side. It's like, well not
in Tampa really. Yeah,
that's about as good and south Tampa
is the best area to live in. Really?
North Tampa is where all the rednecks
live. That's where I grew up.
North Tampa nor Tampa. Is that all
elevated trucks? Shit, you got it.
Fireworks, homemade fireworks,
fireworks, hunting gators,
heightened gators when you were a
kid. Oh, when I, when I, when we,
I'll never forget,
when we went to look at our land,
my dad bought like a piece of land
in North Dakota and North Florida,
Tampa and he was like,
we're going to build on it.
We went out as a family to go look at it
and there were these two rednecks that
had chased this other redneck in his
underwear up on a mound in the middle of
the lake and they were shooting
Bibi's Adam, Mike is your land.
This is our land in my day and
this is our lake and land that,
that little mound and we had a picture
cause it's still there. It's still there.
And they had chased the boy up there in
his and he was in his underwear and my
dad was like, hey everybody cut
it out. That's enough. And My,
they looked at my dad and they go, we
called him fair and square and I was like,
oh my God. And this is private land.
It was like your land. It was a lake.
There's a lake they were on, they were
on a boat. So it was a lake and the,
and it was an island that was like
maybe 10 feet off the shore of where our
house still, it's a big lake. It's a
pretty big lake. It's not all yours.
The whole that is not all ours but a,
but and then the other side of the lake
was like North Tampa. It was lutes.
It's called loot.
We got in the car that day and then
radio stations changed and I remember the
song was downtown loot.
This is their intro to the song downtown.
Lutes kick off your boots.
Give a Holler in who's he hall.
And that was our new neighborhood.
Wow.
Jesus Christ.
Why didn't you research it a little bit
for you fucking bought land there? No,
cause it was,
it was cheap property.
I've heard it's like solid childhood.
I fucking know.
Probably hung gators.
Yeah.
I think the whole state of Florida,
it's considered the south side of the
United States. That's a good point.
It doesn't matter.
The decay of the country.
Florida is a weird fucking place.
I can't go in there next month to Tampa,
Jacksonville and Orlando. Death Squad.
Yep. Oh, well Tripoli. Yeah. Yeah. Let
me set you guys up on my buddy cow head.
All right,
cool.
Callen just got back.
Kallan was just in West Palm.
We were just talking about how
they should have to, you did that.
You should have to have a fucking
passport to get there because you don't
realize like it's like they live
like it's a tropical country.
Like people were just drinking
and partying Barksdale,
but the five o'clock in the morning,
it's a different world.
And if you go to anywhere else in
the country and then go to Florida,
you feel like you're in some
crazy tropical vacation place.
Is Parrots patronizing
is the weirdest thing.
How much everyone drinks and everyone
just gets drunk all the time there.
That's all I remember going to Florida.
Every barge is packs.
You get to take the edge off that meth.
You know what's crazy is I have
friends in Florida who have uh,
who have been to rehab and stuff. One
of the most of the talking on the phone,
that doesn't even make sense,
but it's so funny they consider a
marijuana like bad in Florida of course.
But I've told my buddy, I was like, dude,
why don't you just move to Colorado
and then no one will think you have a
problem.
It's like they wouldn't be able to fit in.
If you live your whole life in
Florida and you go to Colorado,
they're going to go, you gotta
go, you gotta get Outta here man.
We were fucking place.
Florida and Colorado are like
opposite ends of the earth.
They are like polar SPEC. You
fucking, your watch won't work there.
Your compass will be backwards north,
south,
south north to try and get you out of
there. Colorado is perfect for weed.
Florida is perfect for a fence.
What are the next day?
What did the next states that
are going to legalize marijuana?
It's a good question. Not really.
They're going to medically,
but I dunno about legal. Legal.
Medically legal is important.
It's the gateway to legal,
legal.
But what happens is they start feeling
the impact, the revenue impact.
Colorado is making more than a hundred
million dollars this year and way more
money than they thought they were going
to. And the tax rate is crazy high,
39% so if you buy weed,
their 39% of it goes to the government.
So the government is essentially
a drug dealer. And you know,
the people buying it are all tourists.
A lot of the people are buying our
tourists. While we were just in a,
I just did a wise guys and Salt
Lake City. You ever do that? No. Uh,
after hearing you talk about it, I
want to do it. Fuck it was awesome.
Just fucking great.
First
of all, the clubs perfect.
It's the perfect. So everybody
had told me about it.
Diaz told me about it.
Duncan told me about it.
[inaudible] told me about bird was just
there. So I was, I, that's it. I'm gone.
So I, I, I book it,
I go there and it was fucking magic
meant people couldn't have been cooler.
It's like you think like you're going
to salt lake city's bunch of Goddamn
Mormons. No, those aren't
the ones coming to your show.
More means only like 20% of the population
there. The rast is cool as fuck.
Mormons are always cool as
fuck. Nice. I dig Mormons.
The nicest cult members ever.
They're the nicest.
They're less creepy than Scientologists.
Scientologists as second
nicest as far as cult members
were. Scientologists almost switched
me one time. Whoa. What happened?
Dinner Party got a little tipsy and I was
like, so actually I was sober I think,
but it was like a,
and that's when you lost me.
I'm not believing the story anymore. I
was like, you guys believe in aliens?
And they're like, well you could, I
mean you could sit will it down to that.
And I was like, is that, is that weird?
It was this in Tampa is in la or water.
Oh my dad used to represent l Ron
Hubbard. Whoa. Yup. You Dad knew him.
My Dad knew the mother fucker. Whoa. My
Dad. Why did that Guy Die? I don't know.
Long time ago. Right. God dammit.
I wish I had more information.
I wish I listened better. My Dad,
my dad used to come out here,
cause Clearwater is a port town.
M l Ron Hubbard lived on a boat.
So He'd come into different, yeah,
we have a house in Clearwater.
They used to come in to clear water.
They have a huge Scientology center there.
Yeah. It's, it's a huge, my parents,
you still live in Clearwater. Yeah.
So, uh, the eye when I drive it around,
there was like all these
Scientology shit and I was like,
what's going on in there?
Like towns filled with Scientologists.
Yeah, my dad represented
someone. Okay. Are Now,
I remember my dad represented someone
that the church tried to kidnap
dad.
I'm sorry if I'm fucking this up or if
I'm not supposed to tell these stories
because he, he's a lawyer. They knew over
seven years, it's been a while. So he, uh,
he represented someone,
the church tried to kidnapped and hold
because they were trying to get out of
the church and the church was
saying they wanted him back in.
And my dad did such a good job that
the church thing came to him and said,
would you represent, are like
cover all, like whatever it is,
where they pay you money to not, um,
to represent every case they have.
And so my dad did that for like 10 years
and they made it, made a ton of money.
Then the church left him and then
didn't pay for like two years.
He died in [inaudible] 86. Yeah. This
probably, and he died in California. Oh,
interesting. So you didn't die when that
volcano blew up? No, that's not real,
Brian.
That's a dianetics commercial.
I didn't even know you were saying 86
I wonder if my dad will watch thing.
I never asked. My Dad went over our
numbers like 75 years old when he died.
It's probably a Douche bag. Come on.
This is terrible, right? It's a Scifi.
So that was pretty cool. He's probably
a Dork. Wonder if I could do that.
He started,
Bro.
Trust me,
if you guys starts to religion and your
religion is based on some of the worst
science fiction writing of all that.
So here's how they're most switched
me. Okay. Yeah. So they're like a,
so we're at dinner and I said, you gotta
believe in aliens? And they're like,
well yeah, you can whittle it down to
that. And I go, it's Kinda fucked up.
And they're like, well, what's your thing?
And I know you're gonna mock this by go,
I'm Catholic. And they're
like, so you believe in Jesus?
Oh yeah. And they're like,
do you believe that Jesus really like
got gotten nailed to the cross and then
putting a cave and then actually move
the Rock and rose again? I go, no.
Well I mean it's fig. It's
figured it. And they're like,
do you believe that Moses actually
part of the cs are that no,
actually put all the animals on the Ark.
I go know their stories and I,
and they're like, so you are admitting
that there's some holes in your,
in your religion. I go,
well yeah, it's, you know,
and then like do you believe in aliens?
And I go, oh definitely. And then I say,
you actually believe in the
shit that we believe in.
You actually believe there's life out
in the universe. You believe that?
And I was like, Oh yeah. And then I can,
you'll admit that the thing that use your
faith, you have questions about that.
Like why wouldn't you listen to what we
have to say? And I was like, motherfucker,
this is how they get ya.
Cause I believe in aliens.
So when they said that,
did you like open yourself up a little?
Relaxed and go tell me what it down.
She'll shut down.
Yup.
Just like I'm in camp.
And the kid next to me touched my dick
and it felt good and I was like, oh,
that's a boy. Nope. Shut it down.
Or like I'm watching naked and
afraid and I see the ass. I'm like,
that's hot and it's a dude. And I'm
like, fuck, I just shut it down.
Okay, so you shut it down and you
just didn't let him keep going.
What are they trying? Uh, no, they were
soft selling. What's the soft sell? Like?
They always say,
you should come by and put on some fucking
hold these a Campbell soup cans that
are attached to strings.
So they read your mind.
They knew my wife to an acting group.
There's a think called the the
actors camp or actors group actors.
Collum would know exactly what it is. The
actors, it's a Scientology acting group.
It's an Scientology asking group.
And what they do is they'll, uh,
they'll audit you halfway
through the semester,
the audit you and tell you what's wrong
with you and what you need to work.
And when you say audit,
what do you mean?
As a Scientology version of
audit for people think like,
well you gotta check your taxes.
Yeah, Oh yeah, it's a Scientology audit.
The audit you and say this is what's
wrong with you as a person and this is
what's holding you guys back as an
actress. And so my wife was in it,
my wife's best friend was in
it and they came and these,
these two people were in it and
they came back and my wife's like,
fuck that place. I was like, why?
What's wrong with it? She's like,
they said that this, this, this and that.
It was all really accurate and I was like,
what did they say about your friend?
And it was, I mean it was like exactly
what I would've said. I was like,
the Scientologists seem to have a fucking,
they can find your weakness or what
the thing is that fucks you up.
And then once you identify that
it's real and you're like, ah,
I've got to listen to what you say.
Well, they have a lot of a lot of stuff
in Scientology and dianetics itself.
Like they call it dianetics.
That's what the book is based on.
That's a lot of it can be beneficial if
you need a structure in your life and
you need some sort of like a framework
on which to think and how to behave.
They get you with that a lot.
But they also in La,
they run a lot of acting classes. I'd
be the Scientologists who was like, Hey,
when do we get famous?
I was dating this chick,
I don't know if I ever sell the
story of the podcast is great.
This is back in the early days before I
had my no head shots policy back in the
day. Um, yeah, I only dated a few
actions before. I was like, all right,
that's enough.
This is fucking this.
And then I dated a regular girl
and she was so I was like, I'm
done with actresses. Which begs a
question, how did your wife Never Act?
Cause she's very attractive. Uh,
whatever. Anyway, here's my story.
Um, the, uh,
the class that she was in was run by the
scientologist and this Scientologists
guy was like soft sell the whole way.
But he would occasionally bring it up.
Like one of the reasons why he
can get into these roles and his,
cause he's so comfortable
with who he is and he, so he,
he understands who he is as a person.
So because of that he
can abandon that and no,
it's always going to be there when it
comes back and that he can get into his,
and I watch this guy teaching this
class. Like she, this chick was so,
it was so brutal. She would want
you to watch her acting class.
Like come watch my acting class.
I'd sit,
she just needed to be
watched all the time.
She needed massive amounts of attention.
And one of the things that they would
do in the class was a private moment and
that's what it was.
And so you wouldn't be acting out a scene,
you'd be doing a private moment.
So what a private moment is,
you get on your fucking stage and you
start going through like pretending you're
reading your email.
This is like pre email.
So it'd be like reading a
book or something like that,
pretending your washing
dishes. And so, you know,
she would like be walking around like
doing her and people would just be staring
at her and, and she was
doing her shit. I understand.
It's like learning how the idea was
learning how to be completely natural in
front of people and you know, and I go
and I saw, I was mocking it. Of course,
my mock everything and I go, yeah, I go,
that's gonna fucking really help you
when you have to actually talk and act.
Yeah, it's awesome. I go,
it's not at all that what they're
doing is just placating your need for
attention by giving you attention
in this weird way. You know,
like now it's your turn to be the one
that everybody looks at because that's
what the fuck it is. You know, it
was, it was nonsense, but it's,
this guy would give this like Scientology
soft sell that because of my religion
and my, my deep seated
understanding of who I am, I'm,
I'm able to let it all go in a band of
it. Meanwhile, he was at terrible actor.
Oh, terrible. Terrible.
They're all terrible.
Almost all acting teachers saw chuck.
They forced me to get an acting coach when
I got my development deal with Disney.
So I had to take like three or
four classes with this lady.
And I know I've talked about this before.
She was in New York and she uh,
she would fucking, cause I had
a development deal do a sitcom.
She would keep saying that if there was
a part to play my mom on the show that I
was going to get her in front of the
studio and she's going to play my mom.
She's just fucking bitch was crazy.
But I would do, I would read with her,
you know, like we'd have to read and she
was fucking terrible. Fucking terrible.
And then I realize like if she was
really good she'd be out acting like she
wouldn't be teaching goddamn acting class.
And you realize like the only people
teaching acting classes or people that are
fucking terrible at acting.
And then I went on to do stand up,
I mean obviously I was doing stand
up at the time but went on to be more
successful with stand up.
And then I realized that the people that
were teaching these classes were all
these dog shit comedians.
Like when's the last time you saw a
standup comedy class that was taught by
anyone who's ever funny at all?
They don't do it are you should
fear did a seminar thing for comics.
It was fucking great. He did it in
Phoenix and he made a recording of it.
I think he released it as a
podcast but it was perfect.
It was like the only time that I've
ever seen like our real solid stand up,
give advice to young comics did it
for free. Totally free. No class is.
And I think it was sort of his way of
saying like let's fuck these fucking
classes aren't what you need. This is
what you need. This is how you write this.
I get a manager,
this is what you should do,
this is how you should develop material,
this is how you get work. And you know,
spent like a couple hours doing it and
it was beautiful because all it's all you
need. That's all you need. Yeah. The
only thing else enacting class does,
or rather a comedy class does
let you go on stage, you know?
But really the best way to do it,
it's just go to a fucking open Mike night,
right? I think so. Watch kill
Tony. Well that's killed.
Tony is a fascinating podcast for
folks who don't know what it is.
We just did it recently.
Me and dom Irrera and Brian of course,
and and Tony Hinchcliffe
who's fucking hilarious.
We did wiseguys together all weekend,
Utah.
But Tony's show is all about guys go up,
they do a minute and then professional
comics talk to them about their beds and
some,
it's like you get a grab bag.
Some of them are really funny like
that one bricks and bullets kid.
That kid was in from a, yeah.
Oh I know. Bricks and bullets.
Barney cases. First set ever. He did
on the killed Tony that we were on.
Really Funny Kid. He's, if he keeps going,
he's going to be a real comic for sure.
And then the two chicks
that you do it with.
Kim,
Kimberly Kahneman and Sarah wine chick
who write a minute's worth of
new material every fucking week.
Did I do it with them?
Yeah, they're fucking good.
I know exactly what I'm seeing is that
writing a minute's worth of new shit
every week in their whole careers have
been spent doing that from the moment
they first get on stage until now.
Like over a year's worth.
They've been doing sets every
fucking week amid a fresh new minute
that killed Tony was a blast. I did it
with a, did I do it with cigarettes?
Yes. The, and I did one.
It was so much fun. So fun.
It's a real show. And you
know what I was telling Tony,
I was like, this show should be on
comedy central. And that thought about,
I'm like, no, it shouldn't be what it
is. We're thinking of things. Things
we wouldn't be able to do.
Like we wouldn't be able to
have the Iron Patriot guy.
We wouldn't be able to just like back.
No.
While we have fake ones though we
we uh, yeah, we had now and we,
we have like fake sponsors on each one.
We have like we play music in between
when people come up cause it's supposed to
sound like a real comedy
club when you kid up,
you know there's like cherry pies
playing when you were getting on stage or
whatever. I really liked doing that. I'll
tell you what podcasts I really like to,
uh, first of all, Dan
Carlin, if you're listening,
I'm still waiting patiently
for a hardcore, I'm
waiting forever. It's a lot of work too.
I know, I know. I'm waiting patiently.
I'm just letting them
know people are waiting.
That fucking guy puts in some work.
Like those things are mini.
It's like books on tape. I fucking
love them. I sleep to them.
I listened to while I sleep and I
dream that I'm in that scene. Yeah.
The what they do and radio lab dub
does is so different than what we do.
You know, I've done two of these today.
It's easy lifting. It's not fucking,
it's not the same thing.
This is that this is easy lifting.
That first one was that was
like you, you, you were,
trust me when I say you were involved,
like you were listening hard and you had
questions that were very technical and
like I was watching the youth stream
that was not easy lifting said,
but you are also as these lifting.
So I think he was your,
you think he's a great Jujitsu Guy? Oh
well he's the greatest ever. Hixon Gracie.
He's the,
he's the like number one when you think
about like greatest martial artists in a
specific style for Jujitsu, everybody
says Hixon Gracie, it's universal.
It's not like one person says it and
he's also his philosophy and everything.
So it was still was easy lifting because
I really admire the guy and it had real
questions and you know, I knew
him, I knew him for a while,
I've known him for awhile. I've
had dinner with them, you know,
gone over Jujitsu positions with them.
And then,
and then watching you walk in right
when Eddie Bravo and him were discussing
positions and going over them on
the ground, that was cool as fuck.
But now it's still easy in comparison to
what radio lab does or in comparison to
what Dan Carlin does,
especially because he's got
to be historically correct
on all these things as
well. Think about all the different
time periods. He discusses all the,
he's got a read on them, do the research
on and make sure he's got all his, it's
fucking great.
You know what I want to do from an,
I want to do an addition to my podcast
I've been talking about kind of.
I haven't really told anyone. Be Honest.
Be Honest. I know you will. Okay,
so my book did really well, but the
audio book did much better than the book.
Of course people want to
hear me do audio books.
So instead of doing another book,
I'm just going to release an
audio book for my second book,
which will be fiction with me as the
character and just do write a book about
fiction book, audio
fiction book. About what?
About the machine that machine goes,
takes a cruise and accidentally break
let's Somali pirates onto the tray under
the cruise ship and he's then
got to solve the mystery.
Just hear the machine now the machine.
So it'll all be based on my own reality
and lobby based in my own reality of
like were you when you came on to decide
very drunk but I love it. Xanax too.
Nope, just drunk. That's
my idea. Well listen man,
just because I'm skeptical doesn't
mean it can't be amazing. I'll do,
I'll do it just like I'll ride it like a
book, like a fiction book. Cause I can't,
I can't do another fucking
memoir type book. Like I don't,
I'm done stories where you can
do your thoughts on things.
You think a lot about shit. I can, but I,
but I think it would be more fun
to like do a potential shortly.
Remember the book Fletch, like that
character or like saw the movie. I didn't,
I don't remember the book but,
but like I want to do,
but I want to do books like that where
the machine is a character who's got to
solve mysteries.
Listen, if you are a passionate about
it, if you actually think it's fine,
you definitely make it funny.
Yeah, sure. You could make it great. It's
just a matter of, you know, any idea,
if you believe in it and you're creative
and you're good and you chase it down,
it'll either live or it'll die.
I mean,
you could try it and it turned into dog
shit and then you abandoned and after a
few weeks and laugh about it on the
podcast or it becomes awesome. You know,
that's possible too.
I've done some solo podcast where
it's just me talking and uh,
and I was listening to one, like
a, to see if it was okay to post.
And my wife's like, this
is horse shit. I was like,
it's me fucking know.
Oh singing a song about Pi.
Like I was like, cause you getting weird
in your man cave it like, and I was like,
if I was a pirate, this is a song
I had saying, Oh that's so fun.
And so I started singing this pirate song,
but it doesn't sound like me,
but I'm fucking obviously getting weird.
And it's like we are pyre stove.
He's scary. He goes, we're hair look
so funny. Who is this? This is awful.
This is your wife. Listen
to your podcast. No.
She walked into that and she was like,
oh cause I'm listening to it.
She would never expect it. I'm
listening to my own shit. She was like,
Oh this is horse shit. Who is this? I
go, are you being serious right now?
She's like, yeah, it's
really bad. I go, it's me.
She goes, what did she say after that?
She was like, who's [inaudible] podcast?
Who's podcasts we won? She goes, Benson's,
cause she thought I must've been high.
Right. And I was like, no,
this is my podcast. She's like,
this is what your podcast sounds like.
I go, no, this is what I did by myself.
I haven't released. She's like,
don't release it. Don't really sit.
Meanwhile, people are like
on Twitter now you have to.
One of my buddies from the, uh, my book, I
was very honest. I used everyone's names.
I should not have done that.
I know I've got a lot of fucking flack,
but one of the guys whose name I use in
the book maybe first and last first and
land in the middle, in the
middle of that podcast,
he called and go, what the fuck? No, he
was cool. He was like, he was like, yeah,
I heard it was fuck it
was. He was like, yeah,
that's what everyone's been pissed
originally, but then they're like,
then they're like, yeah, I guess I
was a little slutty in high school.
Jenny powers sent me a book.
It was like was really upset.
Didn't Lucy snore Bush get in
touch with Joey Diaz? Thanks.
Because the way you remember
history, especially when you're
writing a book, you do very honest,
like I was just, I didn't
think anyone would. We'll
read it.
Well,
the real problem also when it comes
to people's memories is that they're
terrible, minor, fucking horrible.
Nobody really remembers what I mean.
You will talk to someone who has a
totally different memory of something.
I've had conversations with people that
have totally different memories of shit
that did not,
it just did not go down that way.
It's not possible that
it went down that way.
And I'll explain to them
why it's not possible,
like physical hardcore reasons and
they'll keep going on about it.
Like it's a real thing. I'm like,
God damn it dude. It didn't happen.
Bobby was dead in 86 like you'll tell him
he died in 80 you know he died in 1983
he was in a car accident.
This is,
we were talking about something that
happened three years after his death.
It didn't happen. Cause that happened
three years after his death. Yeah, no,
no mean he was their man.
He's fucking dead.
He was dead and they don't, they won't
let it go. And they just, in their mind,
they have concocted this scenario.
They put these events in a,
in a box and then it no
longer becomes their memory.
It becomes them repeating the
stories over and over again.
And then there's the memory
of the repeated story.
Your memories fucking terrible out,
up to a certain point.
There's like certain very
traumatic moments that I
have reserved in my mind that
are like flashes and then I whatever
remembered is my recollection of those
ideas and what I've said about those
ideas. But those ideas themselves,
like here's a perfect example.
My entire taekwondo career from 1981 to
1988 fighting more than a hundred times.
I don't think I remember more than two
or three flashes of things happening
really. Cause you from head injuries?
No, maybe for sure I have some of those,
but more, um, it just, I
don't know. I just, it just,
I know what happened.
I know I won this tournament,
that tournament and no knock that guy out.
And I know this happened.
I know that was scary.
And I know this was scary.
I know my friend got knocked out, but
my, my actual memories of those, like I,
there's a video of, um, the,
the guy sent me of me knocking this
guy out with is turning sidekick.
And I remember that I knocked the
guy out with attorney sidekick.
I remember that tournament. I'd want a
bunch of fights leading up to the finals.
Um, and one of them was that knockout, but
I don't remember it actually happening.
I mean, I don't remember
it. I know it did happen,
but like if I pulled into my mind,
do I remember the guys coming at me and
I turn and the impact of the kick and
the guy goes flying? Nope. Nope. Don't
remember it at all. That was a pretty big,
it was a u s cup. It was a huge national
tournament was a big event. Nope,
barely remember it. That's so crazy.
That's life though. When I tell stories,
like if I talk,
like I've done some things where like
demonstrate kicks on somebody and they're
like, how the fuck can you
do this? And I'm like, well,
I used to be a taekwondo champion.
I was,
I won the US Open and I'll start and
then almost I feel like I'm lying because
it's not me.
You know?
It's like the meat today is a totally
different person than the May event,
but for whatever reason,
the meat today has retained
all these skills that I
developed when I was younger.
I mean I never let them go,
but the fact that they exist at all in a,
in a way that's impressive to
professionals is very strange.
So like demonstrate a kick, you know,
and show somebody and they're like,
how the fuck can you do this?
I guess I've always done it,
but I feel like I'm lying.
I feel like I didn't really do that.
Like I can't really do that, but I know
I can, do you know what I'm saying?
But I know exactly how
shitty my memory is.
I had someone today on a
meeting and they were like,
tell them how your career got
started. And so I said, well,
99 seven rolling stone magazine found
me and called me the number one party on
the hill country. And he was saying it as
I'm saying it, I go, I'm like, I'm like,
honestly, I said, I thought they
said the day this is fucking insane.
How could anyone prove that? Well, you,
they wrote a story and they
can research the story. No,
and you guys haven't read it.
No one's read. It was like
how many must've read it.
Has Anyone in this room? No, but, but,
but I'm telling them this is, by the way,
this is, I'm laying in bed
thinking this and then I'm like,
I'm the one that's telling everyone that
rolling stone magazine, no one read it.
I mean, I have copies of it
at home. Uh, and, and it's,
it's, you can find it online,
you can read it online, but the
majority of people haven't read it.
They just take my word as, as me going.
And then I started thinking, what if,
what if I like, I got a panicked,
like what if I'm lying, but I'm not,
I know I'm not. But like it's
that same thing you said,
where you go, where you go.
I don't really remember. I remember small
details and stories. I can remember.
I can remember sitting down the day I got
that magazine and I remember dust from
our couches came up and the sun was
coming through our top window at our
townhouse. And I remember seeing
dust particles flying up going.
One of my life's about to change.
And I remember small details of stories
when I met Igor, Igor and Sasha,
Igor who is at the door when I met him,
I remember that I was wearing a purple
Kelty fanny pack that had lemons,
sugar and a knife in it cause
I was going to do lemon drops.
I remember that distinctly because
I fell asleep on lemon drop.
It's like dip sugar and lemon and then
you shoot vodka and then suck the sugar
and lemon tastes really good. It's like
a lemon drop was like a candy if it's,
oh I see, I see. I see. But like I
remember, I remember what I was wearing.
I remember what I was wearing.
I had told them I have a hundred
times when I was wearing the night.
We robbed the train and I,
cause I remember I distinctly remember
and somebody showed me a picture of it
totally wrong. Totally wrong. Yeah.
I was wearing a white collared shirt.
I was like, no, no, no. I was
wearing a blue Obermeyer ski jacket.
I wore that every single day in Russia,
isn't it?
Isn't it weird when someone
has fake memories? Have you,
have you ever had that happen when
someone starts telling fake stories,
like fake memories of you and you're
like, what? I just say yes. Yeah,
because I don't remember
people who were like,
remember the time you were in what you
would call it and you ripped your shirt
off? He brought me on stage.
I was in a diaper. Sure.
That might have happened.
Like Mike Malone,
you say an onstage and a
diaper and you and alcohol.
You might have,
someone told me that you brought Mike
balloon up in a diaper and you were,
and I was like, oh, doesn't sound like
me. It doesn't. It does a little bit,
but I just go, sounds like
you. To me, I go, sure.
It crazy is when you see a picture
of something you did and you're like,
I have no recollection of
that. Yeah, yeah. Oh, totally.
Yeah. Yeah. That's weird.
We've got some old old pictures from our
days at the comedy store that I totally
forgot about it. I'll see it.
I'll go, whoa, that's crazy.
Or some of the videos at Brian
took from back in the day.
You don't even a video of a,
the hooker that we talked to,
their crazy hooker founder a couple
of months ago. You found it. Yeah.
You don't want, you want,
you know what I'd like,
I'd like to go back into
my memories with like, uh,
with some sort of Facebook tagging method
and remember who I met. I used to work,
I used to work out at the comedy store
with Louie Anderson on Sunday nights.
Did he ever try to fuck
you? Nope. Never wants,
but he still has my maid tape from a John
Favreau and Vince Vaughn made and gave
it to him. I was like, it's really good.
Watch it. And then he just kept it an aid.
No note made was a TV movie with
John Febrile, invincible. I was like,
what you were doing, you were, you know,
you went with a dominatrix one time,
you were amazed.
It was something really
funny is, uh, and Louie,
I absolutely love you if
you are listening to this.
He's the greatest guy in the world.
And,
but he had a heart attack during
that time and he was at Cedar Sinai.
And so I went to, uh, went to
go visit him and I was like,
I'm here to see Louie Anderson. It
was like, and they were like, Ugh,
like another one up to the top,
like above.
Apparently a bunch of boys
were just coming in and now,
but like I went up to see him. There were
like three dudes in the room. Fuck yeah,
get yours. Um, wait, what was
I going to say before that? Oh,
I would like to go through and go,
cause I remember sitting in the back
with a bunch of guys that worked at the
comedy store.
Now,
I know that those guys were all
the people that I'm friends with.
It's probably Dunkin and, and like
all those guys probably work there.
And they were telling me how funny I was
and then I should start working at the
comedy store. But I didn't know the
hierarchy that these were all comics.
I just thought they worked at the club.
She,
I gave them like the passing off of
like, Oh, thank you very much man.
I appreciate it guys. And they're
like, no man, you should work here.
Like this is your club. You would
be good here. And I was like,
I really appreciate that.
Thank you guys.
I would love to go back and find
out who I was talking to. That's
wild.
I wonder who that was.
I drove around Louie Anderson's boy
toy once when I was driving limos,
when I just started doing
standup comedy. Um, this, uh,
this fella, uh, Louie
had some sort of a thing.
He was a young guy and uh,
like I would just have to drive
this guy anywhere he wanted to go.
And we were both around the same age. I
mean this fella, I won't say his name,
but do I know him now? I don't
think so. He was a comic sort of,
and he actually wound up writing a
book and went to jail for something,
some fraud thing or something like that.
Cause I remember I wrote
loosely paid attention to him.
And then when you could find people
in the news like Google people,
it was before Google,
it was like, you know,
some fucking net gear search
or some point family. Who was,
what the fuck used?
W W was the early searches
searches though crawler,
uh, [inaudible]. Anyway, this, this guy,
I remember reading about
something that he did. He,
he had some sort of a thing that was
getting attention like a book or something
like that and then you want
up going to jail. But uh,
I was driving him around like I'd have
to take him to the mall and take the end.
He would just tell me,
you know how he's opening for Louie
Anderson and Louie Anderson's,
his friend and this, I had no idea.
And Louie Anderson, it was gay,
but halfway through driving
this kid around and were like,
this kid is gay as fuck. Like
there's something going on. It was,
it was not just that he was,
it was like I driving around a bimbo.
It was like,
you know,
if you were like some rich
oligarch and you had some,
a little piece of ass on the side that
you were, you know like, hey honey,
you know, you want to fucking drive
these guide, take you to store, you know,
you do what you want. It was that
sort of a scenario where, you know,
he was like real cocky and talent,
like giving me advice on, on comedy. Like,
well Louie Anderson doesn't like
this and this is what Louis does.
This is Louise thoughts on, and when
I opened for Louie and I'm like, wow,
Ben bail, you know Ben Bailey? Yes. He
just Kinda, he did it does catch your eye.
But he's a kid. He's a comic. I
mean, he's like are legit comic.
As long as I've known him a
in New York comic, he gave,
he bought Louis Anderson,
he saw Louie Anderson and then it was
like father's day was the next day.
And so he bought his book and then said,
Lou,
will you sign this and
make this out to my dad?
I'm going to give it to him for
father's Day. So he signed it,
just give it to his dad and Ben
gave it to his dad for father's Day.
And then like the next day Ben's Dad
is like, I'm flipping through the book.
You want to talk? Ben's like, no.
He's like, okay, are you sure?
Cause I'll talk to you. I
love you. And it's like, no,
I'm sure the book is all about
coming out to your father.
There
was like,
I'm okay. I think I'm good. Who Was it?
Was it on the podcast that
someone told us a story about uh,
Louis cornering them in their hotel room?
Who the fuck was it?
I don't think it was on the podcast.
I know what you're talking about.
[inaudible] no, no, I think this trip.
All right, let's just let it go.
That's the one we're just talking.
We just got done talking about how bad
our memories are and then we're about to
shame someone. It was Stan hope. I see his
picture right there. Are you serious? No,
no.
Definitely not standard.
Stan. Stan hope has turned spit
takes us into a game at our kitchen,
in our liver, in our, uh, for dinner.
What do you mean Stan hope
we then I did a podcast,
it was like fucking epic for our podcasts.
He told me he fell in love with you.
I fell in love with it so quickly I had,
but he came and sat and had dinner with
my family. Right. And they were like,
when we play games at the table
and Doug's like, I got a game,
let's play spit takes. And they're
like, how do you play spit takes now.
Leanne is not like my wife's Pr, like
pretty regular mom. And he's like,
well I'll tell a joke.
And when you think the punchlines hit
you spit out what you're drinking.
And island Georgia, we're like fuck yet.
Go. So Doug, we'll sell a joke, you know,
as I. Dot I. Dot. Penis. I
said, tell bench penis and
they both spit their drinks.
He's like,
good job.
And so everyone would tell a joke and
everyone do spit takes and the best as
they got to Doug and eyelid told
Doug a joke. I had it on video too,
but I lost my phone and Doug and Doug
does the drink in Iowa says.dot, dot,
dot. Dot. That's how a frog, it's across
the road. And Doug didn't do a spit test.
She goes, Doug, you didn't
have spit taken. He goes, you
don't spit off vodka, honey.
Eila played mustard hands with him.
She goes, you won't play mustard hands.
He's like, how do you play? She's like,
you take mustard and you put squirt it
in your hands under the table and you
either have Methuen mustard in your
hands or you don't. And that's the game.
And dogs like, I'm fucking
in and lands like, no,
I can't get mustered out of
clothes. No. And Doug's like,
don't be a bitch. Come on.
Now. I don't know if he said that, but
you know, you know Doug, he told he,
he Leanne stepped on the eyelids
punchlines and I started crying and Doug
defended Aila. He's like, that's
what it feels like to get heckled.
That island dope. He was the
coolest fucking night I've ever had.
I'm going to go to Hawaii. My wife was
getting shot down and bitched at. Well,
yeah, you can't get what you get.
You don't get upset. Zip It, lock it,
stick in your pocket. You know, you get,
you know, get upset. We got to go, man.
We've got to wrap this up.
I gotta get Outta here.
I want to go to Doug's for the Superbowl
this year. Good luck with that.
I'm going to get mauled
by a bunch of freaks.
It gives us fucking address out to
everyone in the world. Oh really?
Hundreds of people show up. I want to
hang out with them again. I missed him.
I missed, that's a good
idea. The Superbowl party,
it's going to be back in La in August
and Brian and I will be down in San Diego
this week. This week.
Everyone got a bird bird,
bird.com and get my book life of
the Party. I bought you guys copies.
I brought you each copy to read.
Too Bad. Um, I got the IPAD.
Good luck with that shit though.
Well, getting Brian to read Brian.
Brian, when you come on my podcast and
read a chapter of my new book. Fuck yeah,
seriously.
I'm actually late. It's already six 35
here. So let's wrap this bitch up. Uh,
this weekend, uh, San Jose,
Friday night at the San Jose Center
for the performing arts with Tony
Hinchcliffe. Uh, and then Wednesday night,
Wednesday night at the Ice House
in Pasadena. It is bill burr,
Bert Kreischer,
Tom Segura,
Ian Edwards.
Yeah,
I think that's it. And me and a hell
of a fucking show. 15 bucks, 10:30 PM.
Um, and uh, that's it.
Thanks to our sponsor.
Thanks to um,
what did we have today,
Jamie Coplac something real quick.
Sure. I'm in new, in August.
I'm in New York at comics. I'm in Atlanta
at the punchline m at the Richmond,
Virginia funny bone and we
are starting up trip flip.
So if you see me with a film crew,
I am looking for travelers to go
all around the world this year.
Alright. Bert Bert,
bert.com for more details,
go to legal zoom.com use the code word
Rogan naturebox. Save yourself some money.
Yes.
And naturebox as well.
That is our other sponsor at
naturebox.com/rogan. That's it.
Alright fuckers. Thank you
back tomorrow. Much love
God. Bless. Big Kiss. Hug
the kids. Go Fuck Yourself.
Love Ya.
Hm.